One of my favorite things to do with my family is to go on a road trip. We are road trippers. Josh and I love to pack up the car and hit the road with our kids. And I just love the sense of adventure of exploring new places. And we love to use Airbnb. We love staying in a home. We love having a kitchen, having some type of backyard, our patio to sit on at night.
我和家人最喜欢做的事情之一就是去公路旅行。我们是公路旅行爱好者。乔什和我喜欢收拾好车，带着孩子们上路。我非常喜欢探索新地方的那种冒险感。我们很喜欢用Airbnb。我们喜欢住在家里。我们喜欢有厨房，有某种后院，或者晚上可以坐下来的露台。
I love the privacy of it. And also it just feels like you're still at home even though you're on this adventure because you make your own home. And you know, Airbnb is just so great for families because you can really pick a place that suits your whole group. You know, we did that one year with my family.
我喜欢它的私密性。而且，即使你在冒险，也会感觉像在家里一样，因为你可以创造自己的家。你知道，Airbnb对家庭来说真是太棒了，因为你可以真正选择一个适合你们整个团队的地方。你知道，有一年我和我的家人就是这样做的。
We all met up in the mountains and picked this great Airbnb and all stayed in it together. Cousins and nieces and nephews and aunts and uncles. It was so much fun and it was so cozy. And Airbnb really made that family memory special. So use Airbnb for your next adventure. Hey Spotify, this is Javi. My biggest passion is music and it's
我们都在山里聚会，选了一个很棒的Airbnb，大家住在一起。表兄弟姐妹、侄子侄女、阿姨叔叔们。那真是太有趣了，而且非常温馨。Airbnb确实让那个家庭记忆变得特别。所以，下次冒险就用Airbnb吧。嘿Spotify，我是哈维。我最大的热情是音乐，它
not just sounds and instruments. More than that to me. It's a world full of harmonies with chillers. From streaming to shopping, it's on Prime. Welcome to Second Drink Performance Review. Oh, man, I found some fun new stuff
不仅仅是声音和乐器。对我来说，它意义非凡。这是一个充满和声的世界。从流媒体到购物，尽在Prime。欢迎来到《第二次饮品：绩效评估》。天哪，我发现了一些有趣的新东西
for this one. I can't wait to hear, Angela. This episode is really great. We have writer Larry Wilmar on with us to share about his time writing on The Office, and also playing Mr. Brown. Yeah, Larry was our very first writer from the show as a guest on our podcast.
关于这一集。我迫不及待想听了，安吉拉。这一集真的很棒。我们请来了编剧拉里·威尔莫，和我们分享他在《办公室》的写作时光，以及饰演布朗先生的经历。是的，拉里是我们剧组第一位作为嘉宾参加我们播客的编剧。
I know, I love that. Well, Jenna, are you ready for some fun new tidbits? Yes. Performance Review has a fan favorite cold open. on our podcast. I know, I love that. Well, Jenna, are you ready for some fun new tidbits? Yes. Performance Review has a fan favorite cold open. It's when Dwight has decided to ditch having a desk chair and instead he gets a fitness thingy. Yeah.
我知道，我喜欢这一点。好吧，珍娜，你准备好听一些有趣的新花絮了吗？是的。《绩效评估》有一个粉丝最喜欢的冷开场。在我们的播客上。我知道，我喜欢这一点。好吧，珍娜，你准备好听一些有趣的新花絮了吗？是的。《绩效评估》有一个粉丝最喜欢的冷开场。那是德怀特决定不再用办公椅，而是换成了一个健身球。是的。
The ball thing. What do you call it? The ball thing? I mean, it's like a, what's that thing, a medicine ball? But no, medicine balls are the small heavy ones. They're heavy ones. I don't know what I call it. Well, I think the writers were trying to figure out
那个球。你管它叫什么？那个球？我的意思是，它就像一个，那叫什么，药球？但不对，药球是那种又小又重的。那是重的。我不知道我管它叫什么。嗯，我想编剧们也在试图弄清楚
what to call it as well, because I found candy bag alts for it. Oh! In the shooting draft, Jim had this little bit of extra dialogue. He would look at Dwight sitting on the ball thing, and then Dwight would look at him and say, "'Do you know what this is?'
该叫它什么，因为我找到了它的备选名称。哦！在拍摄剧本中，吉姆有一段额外的台词。他会看着坐在球上的德怀特，然后德怀特会看着他说：“你知道这是什么吗？”
And Jim would say, "'It's a hippity hop. "'The good ones have handles. And then they had a series of candy bag alts for what to call it. First Dwight says, it's a fitness ball. It changed my life. Fitness ball. I think that's what I would call it. The next candy bag alt Dwight says, it's a yoga orb. Oh, now we're in the orb world. Okay. The next one Dwight says, it's a fitness orb. Isn't that the one we settled on? That's the one they settled on. I did an internet search and could not find it being called an orb anywhere. Oh what was it called in your internet search? Exercise ball, balance ball, stability ball. A lot of balls. A lot of balls, no orbs. That's what she said. I think our writer's room was having some fun there.
吉姆会说：“这是一个跳跳球。好的那种有把手。”然后他们有一系列备选名称。首先德怀特说，这是一个健身球。它改变了我的生活。健身球。我想这就是我会叫它的名字。下一个备选名称，德怀特说，这是一个瑜伽球。哦，现在我们进入了球的世界。好吧。下一个，德怀特说，这是一个健身球。这不是我们最终确定的那个吗？那就是他们确定的那个。我在网上搜索了一下，到处都找不到它被称为“球”。哦，你在网上搜索时它叫什么？健身球、平衡球、稳定性球。很多球。很多球，没有“球”。这就是她说的。我想我们的编剧室在那里玩得很开心。
Guess what else? What? There was a DVD commentary for this episode. That we never talked about? No! It features Rainn Wilson, Oscar Nunez, Paul Lieberstein, Melora Hardin, Larry Wilmore, Paul Feig, and me. You were on a commentary and you didn't even mention it? No, I didn't. Oh my god. Well, it's got a ton of fun stuff, but I thought I'd share two things. Okay. First of all, when we interviewed Larry for this episode, he shared about the index cards on the writer's room wall. We talk about that in this breakdown, but I learned from the commentary
猜猜还有什么？什么？这一集有DVD评论音轨。我们从来没谈过？没有！它有雷恩·威尔森、奥斯卡·努内兹、保罗·里伯斯坦、梅洛拉·哈丁、拉里·威尔莫、保罗·费格和我。你参加了评论音轨，却提都没提？没有，我没提。天哪。好吧，里面有很多有趣的东西，但我打算分享两件事。好的。首先，当我们为这一集采访拉里时，他分享了编剧室墙上的索引卡。我们在这次解析中谈到了这一点，但我从评论音轨中了解到
that this episode was partly inspired by one of the cards on the wall. Here's what Larry had to say on the DVD commentary. This is the start of the Thursday Friday idea, which I remember that when this episode was put together, there were about four different ideas that were just scrunched together to make an episode. And Thursday Friday was just on the board on a card. And I said, what's Thursday Friday?
这一集的部分灵感来自墙上的一张卡片。这是拉里在DVD评论音轨中所说的。这是“周四周五”想法的开始，我记得当这一集整合在一起时，大约有四个不同的想法被挤在一起做成了一集。而“周四周五”就在板子上的卡片上。我说，什么是“周四周五”？
Oh yeah, that's when Dwight thinks it's a Friday, but it's Thursday. I said, oh, that'd be great in this episode. So it just became part of this episode. It just seemed like a real funny thing to pull under. Oh, Thursday, Friday, just a card on the wall. Thursday, Friday. Larry also said there was a runner with Ryan where he purposely puts himself on a treasure hunt
哦，对了，那是德怀特以为是周五，但其实是周四的时候。我说，哦，那在这一集中会很棒。所以它就成了这一集的一部分。这似乎是一个非常有趣的事情。哦，周四周五，只是墙上的一张卡片。周四周五。拉里还说，瑞安有一个情节，他故意让自己去寻宝
to escape the suggestion box meeting. It's in deleted scenes. It starts in the conference room. Michael takes a to escape the suggestion box meeting. It's in deleted scenes. It starts in the conference room. Michael takes a note from the suggestion box that says, look on the supply shelf. And then Michael asks Ryan to go and look. Then Ryan yells from outside the conference room in the bullpen, oh, hey, there's another note.
以逃避建议箱会议。它在删除的场景中。它从会议室开始。迈克尔从建议箱里拿出一张纸条，上面写着，看看供应架。然后迈克尔让瑞安去看看。然后瑞安在会议室外的办公区大喊，哦，嘿，还有一张纸条。
It says, look on the windshield. Dwight says, which windshield? And Ryan says, it doesn't say, but I'll look on all of them. And he's basically, now he's out. He's in the parking lot. He's out of the office for the day. Do you think this was because they needed B.J. in the writer's room?
上面写着，看看挡风玻璃。德怀特说，哪辆挡风玻璃？瑞安说，上面没写，但我会把所有的都看一遍。基本上，现在他出去了。他在停车场。他今天不用在办公室了。你认为这是因为他们需要B.J.在编剧室吗？
Probably. This was a construct to get him out of all of the background work, I bet. I think so. And then lastly, Jenna, you mentioned in our initial breakdown that there were some great deleted scenes for this episode. I remember there were so many.
可能吧。我敢打赌，这是一个让他脱离所有背景工作的构思。我想也是。最后，珍娜，你在我们最初的解析中提到这一集有一些很棒的删除场景。我记得有很多。
Almost 11 minutes of deleted scenes. And you know, in talking to Dave Rogers, we know a lot of these deleted scenes end up in the superfan episodes, but I think we need to hear a few of them. Great! First, Oscar has a talking head about why he is worried about his performance review. It's really funny. let's hear it. Oscar, I'm ready for you. Today's performance review day company wide,
将近11分钟的删除场景。你知道，在和戴夫·罗杰斯交谈时，我们知道很多这些删除场景最终出现在了超级粉丝版剧集中，但我认为我们需要听听其中的几个。太棒了！首先，奥斯卡有一个关于他为什么担心绩效评估的谈话头。这真的很有趣。让我们听听。奥斯卡，我准备好了。今天是全公司的绩效评估日，
and I'm a little concerned about my review. I exceeded my sick days and my personal days because I just couldn't take it. And I don't have a good answer for him when he asks me. Amazing. Amazing, he just couldn't take it. for him when he asks me. Amazing. Amazing, he just couldn't take it. That's why he didn't come in. And so now he goes into the conference room
我有点担心我的评估。我超出了病假和事假天数，因为我实在受不了了。当他问我时，我没有一个好的答案给他。太棒了。太棒了，他只是受不了了。这就是他没来的原因。所以现在他走进会议室
to have his performance review and he's prepared for Michael to have a reaction to the fact that he's missed so many days. And here's what Michael says. Michael says, so, and Oscar goes, Michael, I don't know what to say. And Michael goes, you're in accounting. Oscar says, yes.
进行绩效评估，他准备好迎接迈克尔对他缺勤这么多次的反应。这是迈克尔说的。迈克尔说，那么，奥斯卡说，迈克尔，我不知道该说什么。迈克尔说，你是会计。奥斯卡说，是的。
Yes, I am. I'm sorry about the extra days. I know it's passed my limit. Michael says, so, good. Something to work on. Being here more. And then he looks around and says, I've always been a believer in people being here more. Oscar looks at him for a beat, then looks to camera and subtly shrugs.
是的，我是。我很抱歉多请了几天假。我知道这超过了我的限额。迈克尔说，那么，很好。有待改进。多来上班。然后他环顾四周说，我一直相信人们应该多来上班。奥斯卡盯着他看了一会儿，然后看向镜头，微妙地耸了耸肩。
I mean, does Oscar not know Michael? I don't, I wouldn't have worried. I don't think Michael's tracking anything outside of his own interests. I know. Next up in Deleted Scenes, Jim asks Michael about his date with Jan. Oh. In baseball terms. And Jim is clearly messing with Michael. I went to the shooting draft and part of this is scripted, part of it is improvised. That's great. Yes it is. Yeah. You have fun? Yes I did. Did you go to first base? Hell yeah.
我的意思是，奥斯卡不了解迈克尔吗？我不，我不会担心的。我不认为迈克尔除了自己的利益之外还在追踪任何事情。我知道。接下来是删除场景，吉姆问迈克尔关于他和简的约会。哦。用棒球术语。吉姆显然是在捉弄迈克尔。我看了拍摄剧本，其中一部分是剧本写的，一部分是即兴发挥的。太棒了。是的。你玩得开心吗？是的，我玩得很开心。你到一垒了吗？当然。
Oh yeah? Yeah. Did you go to second? What? Second? Kind of. Yeah. Over the shirt.
哦，是吗？是的。你到二垒了吗？什么？二垒？算是吧。是的。衬衫上面。
My elbow. Okay so close call on second. Who was their infield fly? Um, yep. call on second. Who was there? Infield Fly? Yep. Wait, yes. Pop-up? No. Later there was. Really? Yes.
我的手肘。好吧，二垒差点就到了。谁是他们的内野高飞球？嗯，是的。二垒差点就到了。谁是他们的内野高飞球？是的。等等，是的。高飞球？不。后来有了。真的吗？是的。
So you got the signal from the third base, Coach. You know what I'm saying? Like if there was a fly out to deep right. You know? That runner on second. if there was a fly out to deep right, you know, I'd run around second. He tagged up, didn't he? I didn't. You know, it was dark for one thing. In the shooting draft, the scene ends with Michael saying, you know, I'm more of a hockey person.
所以你从三垒教练那里得到了信号。你知道我在说什么吗？就像如果有深右外野的高飞球。你知道吗？那个二垒跑者。如果有深右外野的高飞球，你知道，我会绕过二垒。他跑垒了，不是吗？我没有。你知道，一方面天很黑。在拍摄剧本中，场景以迈克尔说“你知道，我更喜欢曲棍球”结束。
Oh, I like that. Yeah. And then Lady Michael makes a phone call that you will not believe. I don't even want to say more than that. You just have to hear who he calls. OK. Yeah, that got a little out of control. Jan's taking a break, which is fine. I'm doing the same. just chilling. Get my mind off of us. She's right, I need to be more professional at the office. When I'm at
哦，我喜欢那个。是的。然后迈克尔打了一个你绝对不敢相信的电话。我甚至不想多说。你只需要听听他打给了谁。好的。是的，那有点失控了。简在休息，这很好。我也一样。只是放松一下。把我的心思从我们身上移开。她说得对，我在办公室需要更专业。当我在
work I need to focus on work. I should call her ex-husband. Hello, is this R. Gould? Hi there, um, my name is Michael Scott. I work at Dunder Mifflin. I believe I work with your ex-wife Jan. Yeah, that's right, yes. I was wondering if I could ask a personal question about her? Okay, well, could I ask anyway? Uh huh. Well, I'm just gonna ask. When you guys were dating, was she sort of easy to get and then really hard to get?
工作时，我需要专注于工作。我应该给她的前夫打电话。你好，是R.古尔德吗？你好，嗯，我叫迈克尔·斯科特。我在邓德·米夫林工作。我相信我和你的前妻简一起工作。是的，没错，是的。我想问一个关于她的私人问题？好吧，那我能问一下吗？嗯哼。好吧，我只是要问。当你们约会时，她是那种容易追到手，然后又很难追到手的人吗？
Yeah, that Gould is a real interesting guy. A gem. Yeah, and then it goes on and Michael's like, well, if that phone call is any indication, that guy is not a nice guy. Like any wonder it didn't work out. It is really funny. Oh my gosh. All right, finally we need to wrap up this second drink with a Michael Talkinghead from Deleted Scenes. I would describe it, but I don't want to ruin it. Another one. Yes, yes. What is an office? Is it a group of people?
是的，那个古尔德是个很有趣的人。一块宝石。是的，然后继续，迈克尔说，好吧，如果那个电话有什么暗示的话，那家伙不是个好人。难怪没成。这真的很有趣。天哪。好吧，最后我们需要用删除场景中迈克尔的一个谈话头来结束这次“第二次饮品”。我会描述它，但我不想剧透。又一个。是的，是的。什么是办公室？是一群人吗？
Maybe. Is it an idea? Of course, yes. Is it a living organism? Exactly, yes. And any single cell organism has to have a spine, and that's me. But the spine is always controlled by
也许吧。是一个想法吗？当然，是的。是一个活的有机体吗？完全正确，是的。任何单细胞生物都必须有脊椎，那就是我。但脊椎总是由
a brain and that is Jan. But the brain needs a heart and that is me again. So ironic. You know what? The heart is smarter than the brain. But the brain is so effing hot. Okay, I am pretty certain I was there when he did that talking head because I am having like a flood of memories come in of being around the monitor watching that and loving it so very much. Oh, I'm so glad that exists somewhere now. Isn't that so great? Yes. The brain is so great? Yes. The
大脑控制，那就是简。但大脑需要一颗心，那又是我。太讽刺了。你知道吗？心比大脑更聪明。但大脑太性感了。好吧，我很确定他在做那个谈话头时我在场，因为我脑海中涌现出在监视器旁观看并非常喜欢它的记忆。哦，我很高兴现在某处还存在着那个。那不是太棒了吗？是的。大脑太棒了吗？是的。大脑
brain is so effing hot. Well, that was my second drink. This is such a great episode. Thank you so much for those, Angela. And now everyone, here is our breakdown of Performance Review with Larry Wilmore. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes
太性感了。好吧，这就是我的“第二次饮品”。这一集真是太棒了。非常感谢你分享这些，安吉拉。现在大家，这是我们与拉里·威尔莫关于《绩效评估》的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供独家的幕后
stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. That's us. Happy New Year. Yes. This is our first episode that we recorded after our two-week Christmas and holiday break. We are back, guys. We're... What? I don't know.
故事，只有两个在场的人才能告诉你。我们是《办公室》女士。那就是我们。新年快乐。是的。这是我们在两周圣诞和假期休息后录制的第一集。我们回来了，伙计们。我们……什么？我不知道。
She didn't have an end to that sentence. I didn't. I was going to say, we're back. We're freezing our butts off. It's cold in here and I just had to wait, like felt like almost a full 10 minutes for Angela to lay all her cards on the desk. It is such a tedious process. Did you say, allow all her cards on the desk?
她那句话没说完。我没说完。我本来想说，我们回来了。我们冻得屁股都要掉了。这里很冷，我刚才不得不等，感觉好像等了整整10分钟，安吉拉才把她所有的牌都摊在桌子上。这是一个非常乏味的过程。你说的是，把她所有的牌都摊在桌子上？
I said, lay out all, lay out all. Lay out all, is that St. Louis? Oh, you're just mad because of waffle ball and chunk it. Hey, you know what? People in Texas say chunk it. Here I was being like all self-conscious cause you said, no, it's chuck it. Then I'm talking to my mom over the holidays
我说的是，摊开所有，摊开所有。摊开所有，那是圣路易斯方言吗？哦，你只是因为“华夫球”和“扔掉”而生气。嘿，你知道吗？德克萨斯州的人说“扔掉”。我本来因为你说“不，是扔掉”而感到自卑。然后我在假期和妈妈聊天
and we're talking about going through the garage and she goes, ah, just chunk it. It's a Texas thing, lady. It is, I will admit it. Cause I came home that day and I was telling my husband Lee, who grew up in Texas, all about the chunk it thing and how much it made me laugh.
我们谈到整理车库，她说，啊，直接扔掉吧。这是德克萨斯州的习惯，女士。我承认。因为那天我回家告诉我的丈夫李，他在德克萨斯州长大，关于“扔掉”这个词，以及它让我笑了多久。
And he said to me, Jenna, I moved to Texas in middle school and I had that same conversation. Someone said, just chunk it. And I said, what? Chunk it? He's like, they say it, they do. It's like pop and soda. Thank you. Right?
他对我说，珍娜，我中学时搬到德克萨斯州，也经历过同样的对话。有人说，直接扔掉吧。我说，什么？扔掉？他说，他们就是这么说的，他们确实这么说。就像汽水和苏打水一样。谢谢。对吧？
Thank you. And I guess- Sorry, Texas. Don't be you. And I guess- Sorry, Texas. Don't be sorry. Just chunk it. And I guess in St. Louis, they say, I'm going to lie on the table. No. Lay out all your cards.
谢谢。我想——抱歉，德克萨斯。别这样。我想——抱歉，德克萨斯。别道歉。直接扔掉吧。我想在圣路易斯，他们说，我要躺在桌子上。不。摊开你所有的牌。
Lay out all your cards. Shall we begin? Let's begin. All right. Performance review, season two, episode eight, written by Larry Wilmore and directed by Paul Feeke. I'm going to give you a summary. In this episode, Michael is supposed to be conducting performance reviews of his staff, but instead he calls everyone into his office one by one to help him decipher a voicemail from Jan. Because if you remember in the previous episode, he and Jan hooked
摊开你所有的牌。我们要开始了吗？让我们开始吧。好的。《绩效评估》，第二季第八集，由拉里·威尔莫编剧，保罗·费格导演。我来给你总结一下。在这一集中，迈克尔本应为他的员工进行绩效评估，但他却把每个人一个接一个地叫进办公室，帮他解读简的一条语音留言。因为如果你记得上一集，他和简
up. They did. They smooched in the parking lot, maybe played some grabby games back at her place. Yeah. And he is convinced now that they are boyfriend and girlfriend. Even though it's clear that Jan has said, this is a one time thing, please make nothing of it, Michael is determined to read between the lines. Also in this episode, Pam and Jim pranked Dwight by convincing him that it is Friday instead of Thursday.
在一起了。他们确实在一起了。他们在停车场接吻，可能还在她家玩了一些抓摸游戏。是的。他现在确信他们是男女朋友。尽管简很清楚地说过，这是一次性的，请不要多想，迈克尔还是决心要解读言外之意。此外在这一集中，帕姆和吉姆捉弄德怀特，让他相信今天是周五而不是周四。
The end of the summary. Summary is done. Jenna, that was a fantastic summary. Thank you. Well done. Thank you so much. All right, you want fast fact number one? I do.
总结结束。总结完成了。珍娜，那是一个精彩的总结。谢谢。做得好。非常感谢。好的，你想要第一个快速事实吗？我想要。
Fast fact number one, I said this is written by Larry Wilmore. You guys, I hope you remember he played Mr. Brown in our Diversity Day episode. Yes, Larry was a writer and producer and an amazing performer. Yes, and we are going to speak with Larry today. Larry is so great. I have such fond memories of working with him. He created the Bernie Mac show. He has been a correspondent on The Daily Show.
第一个快速事实，我说过这一集是由拉里·威尔莫编剧的。伙计们，我希望你们记得他在我们的《多元化日》一集中饰演了布朗先生。是的，拉里是一位编剧、制片人，也是一位出色的表演者。是的，我们今天将与拉里交谈。拉里太棒了。我和他一起工作有非常美好的回忆。他创作了《伯尼·麦克秀》。他曾是《每日秀》的记者。
We've talked a little bit about this super talented guy. I'm really excited to talk to him because he was just, he's so smart and funny. I think that was one of the things about our writers' room is like how fricking smart they were. They were really smart. I think people underestimate how smart you have to be to be a great writer.
我们谈过一点这个超级有才华的人。我真的很兴奋能和他交谈，因为他非常聪明和有趣。我认为我们的编剧室的特点之一就是他们有多么聪明。他们真的很聪明。我认为人们低估了成为一名伟大的编剧需要有多聪明。
Yeah. Like they really go hand in hand. I think, I don't know. Sometimes I wonder, have we wasted all these minds? Should they be off making scientific discoveries? Because some of them were some just like the most brilliant people I've ever met, and they're just sitting writing great jokes.
是的。他们真的相辅相成。我想，我不知道。有时我想，我们浪费了所有这些头脑吗？他们应该去做出科学发现吗？因为他们中的一些人是我见过最聪明的人，而他们只是坐在那里写伟大的笑话。
But then without them, we wouldn't have the fitness orb. Fast fact number two, I was really sick in this episode. You were so sick. Do you remember that? Not only do I remember that you were sick, but I wrote down a quote that I read online. It says- Where did you read this?
但如果没有他们，我们就不会有健身球。第二个快速事实，我在这一集中病得很重。你病得太重了。你还记得吗？我不仅记得你病了，我还写下了一句我在网上读到的引语。它说——你在哪里读到的？
On Wikipedia, on the Office Performance Review Wikipedia. It says, Jenna Fisher came down with a cold. Instead of postponing, however, Fisher memorized and performed all her lines, resulting in fellow cast member Angela Kinsey calling her a trooper. You were in this episode because you were really, really sick.
在维基百科上，关于《办公室》绩效评估的维基百科。它说，珍娜·费舍尔患了感冒。然而，费舍尔没有推迟，而是背诵并表演了她所有的台词，导致同事安吉拉·金赛称她为“勇士”。你参加了这一集，因为你真的病得很重。
But that's one thing I think you guys, I don't know if you guys know this, but when you're on a set and you get sick, you don't go home. No. They literally prop you up because so many people, like what, 300 people, their whole day revolves around that day's filming. Yeah. And so it's-
但有一件事我想你们知道，我不知道你们是否知道，当你在片场生病时，你不能回家。不。他们真的会支撑着你，因为很多人，比如300人，他们的一整天都围绕着那一天的拍摄。是的。所以这是——
They can't shut down the filming just because you don't feel good. Yeah. So a doctor will show up, give you a shot, and you stay at work. Oh yeah. I mean, I've seen them tape people. They're like, oh, have you stopped vomiting for 30 minutes? Let's get you on set and see what we can grab. Oh yeah.
他们不能因为你感觉不好就停止拍摄。是的。所以医生会出现，给你打一针，你就留在工作岗位上。哦，是的。我的意思是，我见过他们给人们贴胶带。他们会说，哦，你停止呕吐30分钟了吗？让我们让你上场，看看我们能拍到什么。哦，是的。
Like that happened. So I was really sick. This was my first time ever having to perform this ill. I took tons of Sudafed. I had a sinus infection. You were a little loopy. I was super loopy. Here's what's crazy.
就像那样发生了。所以我病得很重。这是我第一次在病得这么重的情况下表演。我吃了很多苏达菲。我得了鼻窦炎。你有点神志不清。我超级神志不清。疯狂的是。
At the end of the week, Greg Daniels called my manager about my performance in this episode. And my manager called me, I get this message, Jenna, please call me, Greg Daniels has called about your performance in this week's episode and I wanna speak with you about it. Shataki mushrooms. I thought I was being fired.
周末结束时，格雷格·丹尼尔斯给我的经纪人打了电话，谈论我在这一集中的表现。我的经纪人给我打电话，我收到这个信息，珍娜，请给我回电话，格雷格·丹尼尔斯打了电话谈论你本周的表现，我想和你谈谈。香菇。我以为我要被解雇了。
Yeah. I thought, oh my gosh, this is it. That's it. I don't know why, did you, I, as an actor, especially in the early days and on early shows, I always felt like I could be fired in any moment. Oh, me and Brian and Oscar were always like,
是的。我想，天哪，就是这样。就是这样。我不知道为什么，你，我，作为一名演员，特别是在早期和早期剧集中，我总是觉得我随时可能被解雇。哦，我和布莱恩还有奥斯卡总是觉得，
accounting's totally replaceable. We could be fired at any time. Well, that's not true. But yes, you have this feeling like I'm failing constantly. Yeah. So my manager says, Jenna, we got this phone call and she got all my agents on the phone, too, which you're like, oh my gosh.
会计完全可以被取代。我们随时可能被解雇。好吧，那不是真的。但是的，你有一种感觉，好像我一直在失败。是的。所以我的经纪人说，珍娜，我们接到了这个电话，她也让我的所有经纪人都接了电话，你会觉得，天哪。
They only do that if it's great news or horrible news. Or really bad news. Yeah. So I'm like, and she's like, we received a phone call from Greg Daniels because he wanted all of us to know how outstanding you were in this episode, that it was some of your best work. And to please say, whatever it is you did to prepare for this episode, keep it up.
他们只有在好消息或坏消息时才会那样做。或者非常坏的消息。是的。所以我说，她说，我们接到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯的电话，因为他想让我们所有人都知道你在这一集中有多么出色，这是你最好的作品之一。并请说，无论你为这一集做了什么准备，请保持下去。
And I was like, I don't know what to do with this compliment. Clearly, I'm a fantastic actress on Sudafed. Yeah. Well, okay. Okay. Should I move on to fast fact number three? Yes. All right, fast fact number three
我说，我不知道该怎么处理这个赞美。显然，我是苏达菲下的出色女演员。是的。好吧，好吧。我应该继续讲第三个快速事实吗？是的。好的，第三个快速事实
is also a belated fast fact. I realized I missed something a couple of episodes back in the fight. What? Which applies to all the episodes moving forward talking about cold opens. Oh, do you want to tell folks what a cold open is? Yes, so in a script, scripts usually have like a three act structure where you tell the story,
也是一个迟来的快速事实。我意识到我在几集前的《打架》中错过了一些东西。什么？这适用于以后谈论冷开场的所有剧集。哦，你想告诉大家什么是冷开场吗？是的，在剧本中，剧本通常有三幕结构，你讲述故事，
right? And like a little mini three act. Yeah. Well, we started doing this thing that we called the cold open and it's before the credits and it's a little joke or almost like a standalone moment that might apply later to the episode, but also might not. Might not. It's just like its own little moment. So that was something that our show did. We had these little cold opens. And then we're
对吧？就像一个小型的三幕剧。是的。好吧，我们开始做我们称之为“冷开场”的事情，它在片头字幕之前，是一个小笑话，或者几乎是一个独立的时刻，可能以后适用于这一集，也可能不适用。可能不适用。它就像它自己的一小段时刻。所以这是我们节目做的事情。我们有这些小冷开场。然后我们
also going to start adding tags soon. Ooh, tags are fun. Tags were At the end. At the very end. We would come back from a commercial break and you'd get like a seven second tag. They were very short. Really short. Another little joke.
也很快会开始添加标签。哦，标签很有趣。标签是最后。在最后。我们从商业广告回来，你会得到一个7秒的标签。它们非常短。真的很短。另一个小笑话。
Yeah, they were always really short, like maybe just one page, three lines, just something really tiny. Yes. In this episode, we have a cold open that is one of our most famous cold opens, the fitness orb. Yes. Which is so great and we had a ton of fan questions about this, probably our most frequently asked moment. About this episode for sure. Definitely. For example, Fernanda Fuentes and Derek Ford both asked, how many times did you have to film the cold open with Dwight's fitness ball? And David Nicholas asked, how many fitness orbs did you go through before it popped just right?
是的，它们总是很短，可能只有一页，三行，只是非常微小的东西。是的。在这一集中，我们有一个冷开场，是我们最著名的冷开场之一，健身球。是的，这太棒了，我们有很多关于这个的粉丝问题，可能是我们被问到最多的时刻。关于这一集肯定是的。绝对是的。例如，费尔南达·富恩特斯和德里克·福特都问，你必须拍摄多少次德怀特健身球的冷开场？大卫·尼古拉斯问，在它弹出之前你用了多少个健身球？
Well, everyone, it was not meant to pop. Oh, Jenna, you look really excited. Are you sitting on some info? I'm sitting on some info. I traded messages with Phil Shea. Phil Shea, props master. Yes, he told me all about the fitness orbs. So first of all, he bought 17.
好吧，大家，它本意不是要弹出的。哦，珍娜，你看上去很兴奋。你是不是知道什么内幕？我知道一些内幕。我和菲尔·谢交换了信息。菲尔·谢，道具师。是的，他告诉我所有关于健身球的事。首先，他买了17个。
17 fitness orbs. Yes, and he practiced with John using three of them. Phil Shea sat on them and John like hit them. Phil Shea was such, talk about a trooper, Phil Shea. He's amazing. So the idea was that John would stick the scissors into the fitness orb and it would deflate very slowly. And the camera would be in front of Dwight's desk and you would just see him very slowly melt to the floor
17个健身球。是的，他用三个和约翰练习。菲尔·谢坐在上面，约翰像打它们一样。菲尔·谢真是，说到勇士，菲尔·谢。他太棒了。所以想法是约翰会把剪刀插进健身球，它会非常缓慢地放气。摄像机会在德怀特的桌子前面，你会看到他非常缓慢地融化到地板上
as Jim, very smugly, looks on. Yes, that was what was in the script. So they practiced three times, it worked perfectly, and they had 14 left for the scene. And Phil said to John, as long as you don't hit the seam of the ball with the scissors, which would be like a one in million chance
当吉姆非常自鸣得意地看着时。是的，这就是剧本里的内容。所以他们练习了三次，效果完美，他们还剩下14个用于拍摄。菲尔对约翰说，只要你不把剪刀刺到球的接缝处，那将是百万分之一的机会
that you could do it, the ball will slowly deflate and it will work as planned. So. It's also very hard to see the seam. Oh yeah. Yeah. I mean, yeah. You would have to hit it just right.
你可能会做到，球会缓慢放气，一切都会按计划进行。所以。也很难看到接缝。哦，是的。是的。我的意思是，是的。你必须刺得恰到好处。
Yes. It would be basically impossible to do. Yeah. So they did 13 takes and it worked just right and Yes, it would be basically impossible to do. Yeah. So they did 13 takes, and it worked just right, and everyone was happy, and they were about to move on. And Phil said, I have one more ball. Yeah. So Paul Feig said, oh, what the heck, let's just do one more.
是的。这基本上是不可能做到的。是的。所以他们拍了13次，效果很好，每个人都很高兴，他们正要继续。菲尔说，我还有一个球。是的。所以保罗·费格说，哦，管他呢，我们再拍一次吧。
And in all the 13 takes, you guys, rain as Dwight slowly sunk to the ground, like, whew. Yeah. Right? And it was perfect. So they have an extra ball. They're like, we'll just do one more. Let's do it.
在所有13次拍摄中，伙计们，雷恩作为德怀特缓慢地沉向地面，就像，呼。是的。对吧？而且很完美。所以他们有一个额外的球。他们说，我们再拍一次吧。让我们做吧。
On that last take, John hit the seam. By accident. And you can see the shock on Rain's face. It exploded. And he fell to the floor. We were all completely shocked. We were like, oh my God. And you can totally see John break.
在那最后一次拍摄中，约翰刺到了接缝。意外地。你可以看到雷恩脸上的震惊。它爆炸了。他摔倒在地板上。我们都完全震惊了。我们说，天哪。你可以完全看到约翰破功了。
You can see his shoulders and he very quickly, oh, he's such a pro. He turns his back and he like dives out of the scene. He just like leaves. Phyllis was really surprised too. I swear you can hear somebody say, what? Like either John or Rain is like, what is happening? And they were gonna cut that out. They were like, oh my gosh, we're so sorry Rainer,
你可以看到他的肩膀，他非常快地，哦，他真是个专业人士。他转过身，像潜水一样离开了场景。他只是离开了。菲利斯也很惊讶。我发誓你可以听到有人说，什么？就像约翰或雷恩说，发生了什么？他们本来打算剪掉那个。他们说，哦，天哪，我们很抱歉雷恩，
you are right. We were laughing so hard. And when they went in to edit the episode, they put in what was scripted. They put in the slow deflate. And it was Larry Wilmore, the writer, who said, you have to put the blooper one in. You have to put the fast pop in.
你是对的。我们笑得太厉害了。当他们去剪辑这一集时，他们放进了剧本里的内容。他们放进了缓慢放气的版本。是编剧拉里·威尔莫说，你必须放进那个花絮。你必须放进那个快速爆炸的版本。
Yeah, he fought for that. He fought for that. And he was right. That is an amazing moment. That is an example of just a perfect cold open. And now I think we should take a little break, and we'll come back with our interview with Larry. Yes, we're going to come back and talk to Larry Wilmore, writer of this episode. MUSIC
是的，他为此争取了。他为此争取了。他是对的。那是一个惊人的时刻。这是一个完美冷开场的例子。现在我认为我们应该休息一下，回来后我们将采访拉里。是的，我们要回来和这一集的编剧拉里·威尔莫交谈。音乐
There's so many things I want to do and see. Like redoing the basement without having to do it all myself. Or doing absolutely nothing with a spectacular waterfall view, of course. So I'm starting here, investing with RBC. When it comes to reaching your goals, personalized advice and performance matter. And now you can get $300 when you invest with RBC.
有很多我想做和想看的事情。比如重做地下室而不必自己动手。或者在壮观的瀑布景观下什么都不做，当然。所以我从这里开始，投资RBC。当谈到实现你的目标时，个性化的建议和表现很重要。现在当你投资RBC时，你可以获得300美元。
Offer ends March 3rd, 2025. Terms and conditions apply. Invest with RBC today. [♪ music playing, end credits play out, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends, music ends All right, Sam, let's give Larry a call. Yeah, let's call him up. Hey, how's it going? Hi, Larry. Good. It's so nice to hear you guys.
优惠于2025年3月3日结束。条款和条件适用。今天就投资RBC。好的，萨姆，让我们给拉里打个电话。是的，让我们打给他。嘿，怎么样？你好，拉里。很好。很高兴听到你们的声音。
Same. Oh my gosh, same. We're so happy this worked out. Congrats on the pod, guys. What a great idea, too. Thank you. Oh, thank you. We're loving it. I mean, you know, Larry, we're just two chatty BFFs that get to talk about our favorite job
一样。天哪，一样。我们很高兴这成功了。祝贺你们的播客，伙计们。真是个好主意。谢谢。哦，谢谢。我们很喜欢。我的意思是，你知道，拉里，我们只是两个爱聊天的闺蜜，有机会谈论我们最喜欢的工作
ever. Exactly. From the beginning, from the beginning. Okay. Well, Larry, thank you so much for joining us. Do you know you are our first writer as a guest? Wow. Woo-hoo.
曾经。从一开始，从一开始。好的。好吧，拉里，非常感谢你加入我们。你知道你是我们第一位作为嘉宾的编剧吗？哇。呜呼。
Woo-hoo. And so one of the questions we're asking everyone that comes on is how did it come about that you became part of the office? God, I have so many fond memories of that time. Mine is a little bit more complicated, I guess, than everybody else. I had just started a deal with NBC at that time. I had just done the Bernie Mac show. And I knew Greg from before. I had done a show called The PJs and he was on King of the Hill and we used to see each other all the time and Greg was a buddy of mine and he had never done a single camera show before and NBC wanted to know if I wanted to consult on that while I was developing,
呜呼。所以我们问每一位嘉宾的一个问题是，你是怎么成为《办公室》的一部分的？天哪，我对那段时间有很多美好的回忆。我的经历可能比其他人稍微复杂一点。那时我刚和NBC达成协议。我刚做完《伯尼·麦克秀》。我以前就认识格雷格。我做过一个叫《PJs》的节目，他在《山丘之王》工作，我们经常见面，格雷格是我的好朋友，他以前从未做过单机位节目，NBC想知道我在开发时是否想咨询那个，
you know, just to be another voice in there. You know, of course I thought it was great because I had actually seen The Office years before when I went to England to do this sitcom seminar type thing or whatever and people were screening the sitcoms and I was screening the pilot of the Bernie Mac show and Asha Tallah who was a producer on the original office was screening the comic relief episode I think of the office the one where they wear the red nose is that one yeah and I had never seen the office before and it was great of course you know and we were all like congratulating
你知道，只是成为那里的另一个声音。你知道，我当然认为这很棒，因为我几年前在英国参加那个情景喜剧研讨会之类的东西时，实际上看过《办公室》，人们在放映情景喜剧，我当时在放映《伯尼·麦克秀》的试播集，而原版《办公室》的制片人阿莎·塔拉当时在放映《办公室》的喜剧救济集，我想是他们戴红鼻子的那一集，是那一集吗？是的，我以前从未看过《办公室》，当然它很棒，你知道，我们都在事后互相祝贺。
each other afterwards. And I remember he came to me and he said, Larry, can you promise me one thing? I said, sure. He says, please don't let them take this to America and ruin it. I go, of course not. I said, by the way, if it ever goes to America, I won't have anything to do with it. Smash cut. I don't work here in the American Virgin or the office.
我记得他来到我身边说，拉里，你能答应我一件事吗？我说，当然。他说，请不要让他们把它带到美国并毁了它。我说，当然不会。我说，顺便说一句，如果它真的去了美国，我不会参与其中。快切。我不在这里工作，在美国版的《办公室》里。
And it's funny in the beginning, this is something I don't know if you guys, how much you realize in the beginning of what was going on, that there was a lot of negativity in showbiz about our show. We were kind of sequestered from it, because remember we were shooting in that old warehouse in mid LA that first five episodes, you know? Oh yeah. And people thought we were gonna ruin the office.
有趣的是，在开始时，这是我不确定你们是否意识到当时发生了什么，在演艺圈对我们的节目有很多负面评价。我们有点被隔离了，因为记得我们前五集是在洛杉矶中部那个旧仓库里拍摄的吗？哦，是的。人们认为我们会毁了《办公室》。
Like I would talk to writers around town and they were real snotty about it they said so what are you working on? I said I'm working on the office. They go oh okay I'm like what? It's good guys it's gonna be good and Greg you know as you guys know so brilliant I feel Greg's philosophy was just write it as if we're gonna go off the air you know so you know write ourselves in the corner especially with Pam and Jim and all that kind of stuff and just you know just have as much fun as. So there was such a great feeling in the writers room that we could just do whatever we wanted because, you know, who cared? We might be off the air. Maybe we'll just go for it. That's such a good insight because I felt that way too. I felt
就像我会和城里的编剧交谈，他们对此真的很傲慢，他们说，那么你在做什么？我说我在做《办公室》。他们说，哦，好吧，我说什么？伙计们，这很好，它会很棒，格雷格，如你们所知，如此聪明，我觉得格雷格的哲学就是把它写得好像我们要停播了一样，你知道，所以你知道，把自己逼入绝境，特别是帕姆和吉姆以及所有那些东西，只是你知道，只是尽可能多地玩得开心。所以编剧室里有一种很棒的感觉，我们可以做任何我们想做的事，因为，你知道，谁在乎呢？我们可能会停播。也许我们只是去尝试一下。这是一个很好的见解，因为我也感觉到了。我感觉
like we were making the show in a bubble or making it for our own amusement sometimes. Do you remember our table reads in the beginning? They weren't around a table. We would just sit on the set. We'd all pull up our desk chairs and we'd sit in a circle. And then during our hiatus, I did a guest star and I went in for the table read and it was like a big deal. There was a big table and everyone sat around it and you had like a little placard with your name and, and like your lines had been highlighted and there was network people there. And I just remember that first season of The Office,
好像我们在泡沫中制作节目，或者有时为了我们自己的娱乐而制作。你还记得我们开始时的剧本朗读吗？它们不是在桌子周围。我们只是坐在片场。我们都拉过办公椅，围成一个圈。然后在我们的间歇期，我做了一次客串，我去参加剧本朗读，那是一件大事。有一张大桌子，每个人都坐在周围，你有像这样的小牌子写着你的名字，你的台词被高亮显示，还有网络的人在那里。我只记得《办公室》的第一季，
we really were just sort of like on our own, it felt like. Yeah, we were the little engine that could. What was it like in the writers' room? The way the writers' room went on The Office, especially in the early days, was whatever idea we had would go in a little index card and wouldn't be slapped on the wall. After a while, we had all these ideas that were just slapped on the wall that were
我们真的只是有点像在靠自己，感觉是这样。是的，我们是那个能行的小火车。编剧室里是什么样的？《办公室》的编剧室运作方式，特别是在早期，是我们有的任何想法都会写在一张小索引卡上，然后贴在墙上。过了一会儿，我们有了所有这些只是贴在墙上的想法，它们
just really funny comic ideas of what could happen. And in many instances, the way we created episodes was we put like two or three cards together and that would be an episode, you know. And that's how ideas were generally generated, us just making each other laugh. And whoever came up with the idea didn't necessarily write the show, by the way. It was very democratic in that way. Greg would just hand it out to whoever and you would just write that episode.
只是非常有趣的漫画想法，关于可能发生的事情。在许多情况下，我们创作剧集的方式是我们把两三张卡片放在一起，那就会成为一集，你知道。这就是想法通常产生的方式，我们只是让彼此发笑。顺便说一句，想出这个想法的人不一定写那一集。它在那种方式上非常民主。格雷格只是把它交给任何人，你就会写那一集。
So everybody had a hand in all the episodes. Even though we each went out and wrote a draft, we all contributed to the episode before it went out, and of course when it came back in. You know, and that was a lot of fun. My one regret was in the second season, I came up with that Halloween episode idea and I really wanted to write that one.
所以每个人都参与了所有的剧集。尽管我们每个人都出去写了草稿，但在它发布之前，我们都为这一集做出了贡献，当然当它回来时也是如此。你知道，那很有趣。我唯一遗憾的是在第二季，我想出了那个万圣节剧集的想法，我真的很想写那一集。
I was like, ah! You know, I was kind of salty that I didn't get to write it, but you know, you didn't care, you got over it. It was still fun, but that idea just, just for me thinking it would be very funny if Michael had to fire somebody while they were in costume. It just came from that simple joke, you know, like he had to fire somebody during Halloween.
我当时想，啊！你知道，我有点因为没能写它而感到不爽，但你知道，你不在乎，你克服了它。它仍然很有趣，但那个想法只是，只是对我来说，如果迈克尔必须在他们穿着服装时解雇某人会非常有趣。它只是来自那个简单的笑话，你知道，就像他必须在万圣节期间解雇某人。
And that's usually how episodes just started, from just a central joke like that, and it would expand out to an episode. We so enjoyed your performance in Diversity Day. I mean, we knew you as a writer, we knew you as our writer, producer, but then when you got to perform, you were so fantastic. And then I had just such a new appreciation for it.
通常剧集就是这样开始的，仅仅源于这样一个核心笑话，然后扩展成一集。我们非常喜欢你在《多元化日》中的表演。我的意思是，我们认识你时你是一位编剧，我们知道你是我们的编剧、制片人，但当你开始表演时，你真是太棒了。在那之后，我对它有了全新的认识。
I remember thinking you were amazing when we were filming it, but then watching it, you were so perfect as Mr. Brown. Oh, thank you, Angela. It's so nice to see Ken I had a relationship with as well. He directed the pilot of the Bernie Mac show. And I knew Ken very well, Ken Kwapis, who was the director. And at the time, I was kind of going through a transition in my career.
我记得在拍摄时我就觉得你很棒，但看完之后，我觉得你饰演的布朗先生简直完美。哦，谢谢你，安吉拉。很高兴见到肯，我和他也有过合作。他执导了《伯尼·麦克秀》的试播集。我非常了解肯，肯·卡皮斯，他是导演。当时，我的职业生涯正处于一个转型期。
My evil plan had always been to create a show for myself. I would start my career as a performer as well, as a stand-up and an actor and all that kind of stuff. And I started writing and producing in television because I felt like Hollywood couldn't find me. It was better for me to create a space for myself. I was just the kind of comedy that I did was just a little different. And I really enjoyed writing and producing once I started doing it in after the whole brain actual the
我一直以来的邪恶计划就是为自己创作一部剧。我也想以表演者的身份开始我的职业生涯，做单口喜剧演员、演员之类的。我开始在电视界从事编剧和制片工作，因为我觉得好莱坞没能发现我。对我来说，为自己创造一个空间更好。我所做的喜剧类型只是稍微有点不同。一旦我开始做这件事，我就真的很喜欢编剧和制片工作，在整个大脑实际……
back without will now maybe time to start thinking about this other gear and when i was on the office i remember reading i think i read that part of the table but i didn't have an intention playing it just because i was real busy and i really believe that up you know we should higher actors give actors a shot to do this even though great philosophy in the show if he really one of the writers to perform to which is really fantastic and
回到正题，现在也许是时候开始考虑这个新方向了。当我在《办公室》剧组时，我记得我读过，我想我读过剧本的那一部分，但我并没有打算出演，只是因为我真的很忙，而且我真的相信，你知道，我们应该聘请演员，给演员们机会来做这件事，尽管剧中的理念非常棒，如果他真的想让编剧们去表演，那真的很棒，而且
you know people like mendi and bj and even paul leaver steam who by the way i had hired on the bring back to i had no idea paul that could have been after i would have heard about my trip he's so great headache david such a interesting feel you know to have writers being a part of it and to have you know people who were in the background like angelo some of the ad
你知道像门迪和BJ，甚至保罗·利伯斯坦，顺便说一下，我也在《伯尼·麦克秀》里雇佣过他，我根本不知道保罗……那可能是在我听说我的旅行之后，他太棒了，头疼，大卫，你知道，让编剧参与其中，让那些在背景里的人，比如安吉拉，还有一些助理导演，这是一种非常有趣的体验。
that you got started doing in the life the way you guys brought those characters to life but not really a lot of material in the beginning with fantastic you know just even the looks you guys gave in all that stuff really gave this organic feel to you, you know. But in the beginning, I really didn't want to play that part and Ken kind of talked me into it. You know, I just wasn't thinking about it. I just thought, yeah, we should be bringing in actors. But then I realized that's kind of what we're doing on the show is we're all kind of like pitching into this
你们开始做的方式，你们赋予这些角色生命的方式，虽然一开始并没有太多的素材，但真的很棒，你知道，甚至你们给出的眼神，所有这些东西真的给了它一种有机的感觉，你知道。但在开始的时候，我真的不想演那个角色，是肯说服了我。你知道，我只是没往那方面想。我只是觉得，是的，我们应该引入演员。但后来我意识到，这正是我们在剧中所做的，我们都在为这个
thing. So once I embraced it, I just ended up just having a lot of fun. And by the way, I saved some of those outtakes from it and steve carroll so hilarious as you remember when he was doing the whole chris rock thing it was just so funny i was just crying laughing which we probably couldn't even do that episode today you know because it was uh... so inappropriate so many glorious way in the new do people approach you and call you mister brown all the time it's crazy people came like i have all these different, I guess,
事情做出贡献。所以一旦我接受了它，我最终玩得很开心。顺便说一下，我保存了一些花絮，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔太搞笑了，你还记得他做克里斯·洛克那个桥段的时候吗？真是太搞笑了，我当时笑得眼泪都出来了，我们今天可能甚至都不能拍那一集了，你知道，因为它太……太不合适了，以至于在很多方面都很辉煌。人们会一直走过来叫你布朗先生吗？这太疯狂了，人们就像，我想我有所有这些不同的，
identities to people. Like, some people know me from The Nightly Show, The Daily Show. Some people just know me from The Office and from that role, you know, and from other things that I do. But it's amazing. And they don't say Larry Wilmore. They say Mr. Brown.
对人们来说的身份。比如，有些人通过《深夜秀》、《每日秀》认识我。有些人只是通过《办公室》和那个角色认识我，你知道，还有我做的其他事情。但这很神奇。他们不叫拉里·威尔莫，他们叫布朗先生。
Like, that's what they say. And that's it. Done. That's who I am in their minds. It's not going to change. But I's it, done. That's who I am in their minds. It's not gonna change. But I consider it an honor. I think, how many times, guys, do you get to play a part where I was on screen for what?
就像，他们就是这么说的。就这样。结束了。在他们心中我就是那个人。这不会改变。但我把它视为一种荣誉。我想，伙计们，你们有多少次能扮演一个我在屏幕上出现……
A minute and a half, two minutes? And people remember that years later, the character's name? I mean, that's an honor to do that. So the biggest thing people wanna know about this episode, Angela, you went through the questions. It's about the suggestion box. They all want to know what was written, what was improvised.
一分半钟，两分钟的角色？而人们多年后还记得那个角色的名字？我的意思是，能做到这一点是一种荣誉。所以人们想知道关于这一集最大的事情，安吉拉，你浏览了这些问题。是关于意见箱的。他们都想知道写了什么，什么是即兴创作的。
I know I got one line improvised in there that made it in, but they were wondering what were ones that didn't get read? You guys must have pitched all kinds of things for that suggestion box. Not as much as people would think. I think pretty much my first draft made it through, I think, to the floor on that one. The way that when I wrote that, remember the old Johnny Carson show where his sidekick was Ed McMahon, and Johnny would do this bit called Karnak where he would read something and Ed would repeat it. The fur from a camo,
我知道我有一句即兴台词被采纳了，但他们想知道有哪些没被读出来？你们一定为那个意见箱投递了各种各样的东西。没有人们想象的那么多。我想基本上我的初稿就通过了，我想，在那一集里。当我写那个的时候，记得老约翰尼·卡森秀吗？他的搭档是艾德·麦克马洪，约翰尼会做一个叫卡纳克的桥段，他会读一些东西，艾德会重复它。来自骆驼的毛，
and then Ed would go, the fur from a camo, yes. And he would do this thing the thing and it was so ridiculous and I thought it would be very funny to put the white in that position where you have to repeat these things with Michael and that's kind of how I constructed it comedically but it was you know the way that it was constructed was very careful to lead you know to the way that it did you know so I don't remember there being a lot in the suggestion, but my recollection of it is that those things were chosen very carefully to go down a certain path, rather than have a lot of things that were in there. That's kinda how I remember it.
然后艾德会说，来自骆驼的毛，是的。他会做这个事情，这太荒谬了，我想把迈克尔放在那个位置会非常有趣，你必须和迈克尔一起重复这些事情，这在某种程度上是我在喜剧上构建它的方式，但你知道，它的构建方式非常小心，以引导你知道它最终呈现的方式，你知道，所以我记得意见箱里并没有很多东西，但我对它的记忆是，那些东西被非常仔细地选择，以走上一条特定的道路，而不是里面有很多东西。这就是我记忆中的样子。
That makes total sense to me. It makes total sense, and also, if you think about it like that when you watch it, there are camera movements that look very deliberate, because you're panning to the people that have something to say. The thing that was great about The Office is things that feel like, by the way, of course, it was a very talented cast and your guys' ability to improvise was great, but the opposite was we were lucky to have on that too, is that we also created moments that looked very
这对我来说完全说得通。这完全说得通，而且，如果你在观看时这样想，有些摄像机的移动看起来非常刻意，因为你在平移到那些有话要说的人身上。关于《办公室》最棒的事情是那些感觉，顺便说一下，当然，这是一个非常有才华的演员阵容，你们即兴表演的能力很棒，但相反的是，我们也很幸运能拥有这一点，那就是我们也创造了一些看起来非常
real and that sort of thing, and that was kind of the magic of the shows. We have both of those elements in the show. And so that scene, you know, I remember very carefully writing that scene because I knew the rhythm was important and it the comedic rhythm, you know. And so I think that's why there wasn't a lot of rewriting on it because it had that certain rhythm
真实的东西，这就是剧集的魔力所在。我们在剧集中同时拥有这两个元素。所以那一幕，你知道，我记得非常仔细地写了那一幕，因为我知道节奏很重要，它是喜剧节奏，你知道。所以我认为这就是为什么它没有太多的重写，因为它有那种我们想要保持完整的特定节奏。
to it that we wanted to kind of keep intact in it. Well, I think something you were mentioning that people often don't realize how written the office is, that people think it's mostly improvised, which it's not. It's mostly scripted. But you guys would even script some of those looks. In the script, it would say, camera pans to catch Angela looking judgy by her desk.
嗯，我想你提到的事情，人们通常没有意识到《办公室》写得有多细致，人们认为它大部分是即兴创作的，其实不然。它大部分是有剧本的。但你们甚至会把那些眼神也写进剧本里。在剧本里，它会写，摄像机平移捕捉到安吉拉在办公桌前看起来很爱评判的样子。
You started to write in those moments. Yeah, and it is that combination of thing. It's the combination of us seeing what you guys were doing and then writing towards it. So it's the push and pull of that, you know. Especially like, that's why those first five episodes are so important because all the stuff that, you know, you guys were doing, we noticed all of those things. Because remember, during those early days, I think all the stuff that you guys were doing, we noticed all of those things. Because remember, during those early days, I think all the writers were on the set the whole time.
你开始写进那些时刻。是的，这就是那种组合。这是我们看到你们在做什么，然后针对它进行创作的组合。所以这是一种推拉，你知道。特别是，这就是为什么前五集如此重要，因为所有那些，你知道，你们在做的事情，我们都注意到了所有这些。因为记住，在那些早期的日子里，我想所有那些你们在做的事情，我们都注意到了。因为记住，在那些早期的日子里，我想所有的编剧都在片场。
I think we were all there watching it. And just learning from what you guys were doing and trying to write towards it and that kind of stuff to help develop it and everything. It did feel like a real creative collaboration. I always felt that way. And it's something- It really was. I miss when we go to other shows now and work on other things. I know, it's just not the same. Kudos to Greg Daniels who just wanted to do it differently, wanted to do this collaborative process with both the writers and the actors and performers.
我想我们都在那里看着它。只是从你们所做的事情中学习，并试图针对它进行创作，诸如此类的事情来帮助发展它等等。这确实感觉像是一个真正的创意合作。我一直都有这种感觉。而且这是某种——确实如此。我现在去其他剧组工作时很怀念这一点。我知道，这不一样。向格雷格·丹尼尔斯致敬，他只是想以不同的方式去做，想与编剧和演员们进行这种合作过程。
No one felt threatened by it. Think about Steve Carell who's the star of the show never felt threatened by any of this stuff you know and just was so collaborative and just funny and just love for other people to shine because we've been in business long enough we know how that can be the opposite you know where you know who's this person getting all these laughs you know why am I not getting these laughs here? The show had something else that was really special. As you remember, Steve Merchant was also the co-creator
没有人因此感到受到威胁。想想史蒂夫·卡瑞尔，他是剧中的明星，从未对这些事情感到受到威胁，你知道，只是非常乐于合作，而且很有趣，只是喜欢让其他人发光，因为我们在这一行待得够久了，我们知道相反的情况会是什么样子，你知道，谁是这个得到所有笑声的人，你知道为什么我没有得到这些笑声？这部剧还有一些非常特别的东西。正如你记得的那样，史蒂夫·麦钱特也是该剧的联合创作者，
of the show with Ricky Gervais. And they would come by sometimes. And I remember talking to Steve about it, of what he felt the show really was. And from Steve Merchant always said that for him, the show was a romantic comedy. And it was his idea of the show was really about Jim and Pam. You know, Tim and Don was the show to him, Jim and Pam.
与瑞奇·热维斯一起。他们有时会过来。我记得和史蒂夫谈过这件事，关于他认为这部剧到底是什么。史蒂夫·麦钱特总是说，对他来说，这部剧是一部浪漫喜剧。他认为这部剧是关于吉姆和帕姆的。你知道，蒂姆和唐是剧集，对他来说，吉姆和帕姆才是。
And to have that as part of our show, guys, it gave it this great, gorgeous center that was always something great to go to. It really made like the harsh humor or the outrageous humor. It gave it a center that was special because we really want to root for these people we haven't quite seen something like that you know and i never forgot that i was like wow you know
能把这一点作为我们剧集的一部分，伙计们，它给了它一个伟大的、华丽的中心，总是可以去往伟大的地方。它真的让那种尖刻的幽默或离谱的幽默变得特别，因为它给了它一个中心，因为我们真的想支持这些人，我们还没有完全见过这样的东西，你知道，我永远不会忘记这一点，我当时想，哇，你知道，
sometimes in our minds we're thinking of funny jokes and outrageous things yet diversity date both those things are funny but when you have that romantic story inside of it managed to raise it to that next level. To me, it's really what made, especially in those early years, you know, when we didn't know what was going to happen with them, you know, what's going on here, is this guy getting heartbroken, does Pam know what she's doing, you know, all those questions, even when we didn't quite answer them, they were always lurking in there.
有时在我们的脑海里，我们想的是有趣的笑话和离谱的事情，然而《多元化日》这两件事都很有趣，但当你里面有那个浪漫故事时，它成功地将其提升到了一个新的水平。对我来说，这确实是让它，特别是在那些早期，你知道，当我们不知道他们会发生什么时，你知道，这里发生了什么，这个家伙心碎了吗，帕姆知道她在做什么吗，你知道，所有这些问题，即使我们没有完全回答它们，它们也总是潜伏在那里。
And things like that really enrich your story, you know, It really makes it a joy to write that type of thing. Even to this day, I'm still trying to figure out a romantic comedy to do on television. I think it's kind of underserved. Larry, thank you so much for coming to be on our podcast. I know you're super busy. You have a ton in development. You're producing so many things. One of my goals always has been representation, trying to put stuff on television,
像这样的事情真的丰富了你的故事，你知道，写那种东西真是一种乐趣。即使到了今天，我仍然在试图弄清楚在电视上做什么样的浪漫喜剧。我认为它有点被忽视了。拉里，非常感谢你来参加我们的播客。我知道你超级忙。你有很多开发中的项目。你正在制作这么多东西。我的目标之一一直是代表性，试图在电视上展示一些东西，
whether it's people we don't get a chance to see or stories we don't get a chance to see, always as much as possible. So that's always in the back of my mind. And you have a podcast. Yeah. Larry Wilmore Black on the Air. People can catch on the Ringer Networks, too. Thank you so much for coming on.
无论是我们没有机会看到的人，还是我们没有机会看到的故事，总是尽可能多地展示。所以这总是在我的脑海里。而且你有一个播客。是的。拉里·威尔莫的《Black on the Air》。人们也可以在Ringer Networks上收听。非常感谢你来参加。
This is amazing. Thanks for having me, guys. I remain big fans of both of you. Congrats on all your great success. So you guys have to come on my podcast now, now that I did yours. Okay, deal. It's a date.
这太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我，伙计们。我仍然是你们两人的忠实粉丝。祝贺你们取得的所有巨大成功。既然我参加了你们的，你们现在必须来参加我的播客。好的，成交。一言为定。
Okay, you got it. Sounds great. All right, Larry, thank you so much. Thank you, Larry, we love you. Aw, that was so great. He's so smart and funny. Why do I get so emotional every time we just hear the voices of the people we worked with? Because we were a family.
好的，没问题。听起来很棒。好的，拉里，非常感谢。谢谢你，拉里，我们爱你。噢，那太棒了。他太聪明、太有趣了。为什么每次我们听到我们合作过的人的声音时，我都会变得如此情绪化？因为我们是一个家庭。
We were a family. All right, well, we're going to take a break so I can be emotional. I'll pull myself together and we'll be back to break down the episode. ["The Daily Show Theme"] Larry is fantastic. That was great.
我们是一个家庭。好的，好吧，我们要休息一下，这样我才能平复一下情绪。我会调整好自己，然后回来解析这一集。["每日秀主题曲"] 拉里太棒了。那太棒了。
That was great. That was so fun to talk to him. We're so lucky. We're so lucky. All right, should we get into the episode? Let's get into performance review. I know we covered a little bit of the stunt aspect of the fitness orb, but we have not discussed the other elements of the cold open.
那太棒了。和他聊天真有趣。我们太幸运了。我们太幸运了。好的，我们要开始讲这一集了吗？让我们进入《绩效评估》。我知道我们讨论了一点健身球的特技方面，但我们还没有讨论冷开场的其他元素。
The romance. You mean the look to camera that Dwight gave at 50 seconds? Yes. When Jim is like, you're not having sex. He's like, mm-hmm. What does that look about? I think we're going to find out. I think we might. All right, so in the first scene,
浪漫。你是说德怀特在50秒时给摄像机的那个眼神吗？是的。当吉姆说，你没有做爱。他说，嗯哼。那个眼神是什么意思？我想我们会找到答案的。我想我们可能会。好的，所以在第一幕中，
Oscar is walking out of Michael's office. He's just completed his performance review. And Michael calls Pam into his office. I think you can tell in my talking head there that I'm very sick. I don't know. I think I sound very nasally. I mean, if you can't tell, you're literally like, here's the performance review. So in that office, when Michael makes Pam listen to the voicemail from Jan, that was
奥斯卡正走出迈克尔的办公室。他刚刚完成了他的绩效评估。迈克尔叫帕姆进他的办公室。我想你可以从我的谈话头中看出我病得很重。我不知道。我觉得我的鼻音很重。我的意思是，如果你看不出来，你简直就像是，这是绩效评估。所以在那个办公室里，当迈克尔让帕姆听简的语音留言时，那是
my sickest day. That was Jan, that was my sickest day. That was the day I was most sick. And I think you can see me a little bit nodding off, like not nodding off. I think you can see me drifting from the Sudafed. Like I'm a little like, hey. Your eyes are a little glassy. A little dilated. They are. They're a little glassy. But it has one of my favorite scenes. Jenna, it made me laugh so hard. You and Steve were so great.
我病得最重的一天。那是简，那是我病得最重的一天。那是我病得最重的一天。我想你可以看到我有点打瞌睡，不是打瞌睡。我想你可以看到我因为苏达菲而神志不清。就像我有点，嘿。你的眼睛有点玻璃状。有点放大。是的。它们有点玻璃状。但它有我最喜欢的场景之一。珍娜，它让我笑得太厉害了。你和史蒂夫太棒了。
And I just loved when he's like, Pam, you're trustworthy. Wait, can we re, let's act it out. Yeah. Do it. All right. I'll be Michael. You be yourself. Ready?
我特别喜欢他说，帕姆，你很值得信赖。等等，我们可以重演一下吗？是的。演吧。好的。我演迈克尔。你演你自己。准备好了吗？
All right. Pam, you're trustworthy. Thank you. And a woman. Oh, no. It made me laugh so hard. I know. She just knows where that's going.
好的。帕姆，你很值得信赖。谢谢。而且是个女人。哦，不。它让我笑得太厉害了。我知道。她只是知道那会走向何方。
And it's not good news. So we had a fan question about this from Luke J. Was the scene with you talking to Michael about Jan's voicemails improvised? No, it wasn't. But here's an interesting fact. We weren't listening to a recording. That was actually Melora, who plays Jan, on the phone
而且不是什么好消息。所以我们有一个来自卢克·J的粉丝问题。你和迈克尔谈论简的语音留言的那一幕是即兴创作的吗？不，不是。但这里有一个有趣的事实。我们听的不是录音。那实际上是扮演简的梅洛拉在电话里
saying that voicemail in the exact same way over and over again. Yeah. And he would hit that button. He would hit that button and she would be cued to say it. I think she was right in the conference room. I think she was right around the corner. She was.
一遍又一遍地用完全相同的方式说那段语音留言。是的。他会按下那个按钮。他会按下那个按钮，她就会被提示说出来。我想她就在会议室里。我想她就在拐角处。她确实在。
She was on set talking through the phone. And I feel like our second AD would cue her whenever Michael hit the button. She might could have even have seen him actually, depending where she was standing. That was so funny. So good. And there's deleted scenes. And if you look at it, there's one deleted scene where Steve keeps pressing the button like 12 times.
她在片场对着电话说话。我觉得我们的第二助理导演会在迈克尔按下按钮时提示她。她甚至可能真的能看到他，取决于她站在哪里。那太搞笑了。太好了。还有删除的场景。如果你看的话，有一个删除的场景，史蒂夫一直按那个按钮按了12次。
And she just had to keep saying, I guess I missed you. I guess I missed you. I guess I missed you. I guess I missed you until she starts laughing. Until she goes, yeah, because it was like insane. Okay, at two minutes and 51 seconds, there was a flashback to the exterior of the chilies
她不得不一直说，我想我错过了你。我想我错过了你。我想我错过了你。我想我错过了你，直到她开始笑。直到她说，是的，因为它太疯狂了。好的，在2分51秒，有一个闪回，是辣椒餐厅的外部，
and you get a wide shot of that chilies from the previous episode that we talked about and you see them kissing outside. I really scrutinize this shot of the chilies, Angela. I wanna hear it. Remember in the last episode we said, was this the same chilies that we shot the Dundies? Oh yeah, you were obsessed with that. Now I think to hear it. Remember in the last episode we said, was this the same Chili's that we shot the Dundee's? Oh yeah, you were obsessed with that.
你看到了我们之前讨论过的上一集里的那个辣椒餐厅的广角镜头，你看到他们在外面接吻。我真的仔细检查了这个辣椒餐厅的镜头，安吉拉。我想听听。记得在上一集我们说，这是我们拍摄邓迪奖的那个辣椒餐厅吗？哦，是的，你对此很着迷。现在我想听听。记得在上一集我们说，这是我们拍摄邓迪奖的那个辣椒餐厅吗？哦，是的，你对此很着迷。
Now I think it was not. Really? Based on the exterior. Of the parking lot? Yes. This shot is different than any shot we got in the client. This is a wide shot. And I think it looks like a different parking
现在我想它不是。真的吗？基于外部。停车场？是的。这个镜头和我们在《客户》中得到的任何镜头都不同。这是一个广角镜头。而且我觉得它看起来像是一个不同的停车场
lot and a different exterior than the one that Pam comes out of the Dundee's screaming, woohoo. All right, I'm going to have to go back and look at that. Okay. Way to go, lady. Also, maybe no one cares, but- We all care. I have a card from Five Minutes. Is that jumping too far ahead for you? Who knows? Okay. Who knows? I don't write time codes. I have a card for Five Minutes, Five Seconds. It's just me commenting, commenting you guys as a fan. I just thought John's reaction when he is Jim realizes that Dwight thinks it's the wrong date. His performance in that little moment is so brilliant cause it's really letting you in on
和不同的外部，而不是帕姆尖叫着“呜呼”走出邓迪奖的那个。好的，我得回去看看。好的。干得好，女士。另外，也许没人关心，但是——我们都关心。我有一张五分钟的卡片。这对你来说跳得太远了吗？谁知道呢？好的。谁知道呢？我不写时间码。我有一张五分五秒的卡片。那只是我作为粉丝评论你们。我只是觉得约翰在吉姆意识到德怀特认为日期错了时的反应。他在那一刻的表演太精彩了，因为它真的让你意识到
that he's figuring something out. And it's subtle and it's perfect. And John, you crushed it. Yeah, those are the ways that John just like, he's amazing. He's so good. John, you crushed it. Yeah, those are the ways that John just like, he's amazing. He's so good, John, you're so good. I'm like, I'm just like, I've always been a fan and I think I'm just like,
他在弄清楚某件事。这很微妙，而且很完美。约翰，你演得太棒了。是的，这就是约翰的方式，他太棒了。他太好了。约翰，你演得太棒了。是的，这就是约翰的方式，他太棒了。他太好了，约翰，你太好了。我就像，我一直都是粉丝，我想我只是，
becoming a bigger fan as I rewatch. Here's something about that same scene. I don't know if you noticed, but in the background over John's shoulder, Michael's door is closed. Here's a little tidbit. When you see scenes between Jim and Dwight and Michael's door is closed, that meant that Steve didn't have to sit in there.
随着重看变得越来越大的粉丝。关于同一场景，这里有一件事。我不知道你有没有注意到，在约翰肩膀后的背景里，迈克尔的门是关着的。这里有一个小花絮。当你看到吉姆和德怀特之间的场景，而迈克尔的门是关着的时候，这意味着史蒂夫不必坐在里面。
Oh, good for Steve. Yeah, he would get a break from having to do the background work because when the door was open, you could see him at his desk, but when the door is closed, you can't. Guess what? None of the rest of us had doors. Nope. None of the rest of us had doors. Unless you're in the annex. So Steve got out of the background for that couple of hours that we shot that scene. I have a card for seven minutes, 50 seconds. You guys, it's a scene in accounting. So here's the thing. When Brian and Oscar and I got to have a scene that was solely in accounting, we would get just giddy.
哦，这对史蒂夫来说很好。是的，他可以从背景工作中休息一下，因为当门打开时，你可以看到他在办公桌前，但当门关上时，你不能。猜猜怎么着？我们其余的人都没有门。没有。我们其余的人都没有门。除非你在附属建筑里。所以史蒂夫在拍摄那一幕的那几个小时里从背景中解脱出来了。我有一张七分五十秒的卡片。伙计们，这是会计部的一幕。所以事情是这样的。当布莱恩、奥斯卡和我有一场完全在会计部的戏时，我们会变得非常兴奋。
We would get so excited and like, we would come up with all of these bits and they would always be like, guys, we don't have time for all of that. We used to joke, you know, like I would say like, guys, it's not our show. It's not called The Accountants. So we were really excited.
我们会变得非常兴奋，就像，我们会想出所有的桥段，他们总是会说，伙计们，我们没有时间做所有这些。我们过去常开玩笑，你知道，就像我会说，伙计们，这不是我们的剧。它不叫《会计师》。所以我们真的很兴奋。
But when I was watching this, I thought, oh my God, Kevin is such a gossip. Oh, yes. He's so gossipy when he's like, they made out, you know, and how it sucks. He's being so gross. And then of course, what the heck does my comment mean when I say office romances are nobody's business but the people involved?
但当我观看这一幕时，我想，天哪，凯文真是个八卦精。哦，是的。当他说，他们亲热了，你知道，以及这有多糟糕时，他真是太八卦了。他表现得太恶心了。然后当然，当我说办公室恋情不关任何人的事，只关当事人的事时，我的评论是什么意思？
What's happening between Dwight's look and that line? I know. Mm-hmm. We're weaving something together here. Something's happening. I want to talk about Stanley's meeting with Michael. Oh gosh. You know what?
德怀特的眼神和那句台词之间发生了什么？我知道。嗯哼。我们在这里编织着什么。有什么事情正在发生。我想谈谈斯坦利和迈克尔的会面。哦，天哪。你知道吗？
Leslie David Baker is so brilliant in this scene. I actually wanted to call Leslie. Dang it. Okay, Leslie, we're going to call you. You've got to come in. I wrote on a card. Just read what I wrote. On the ghetto.
莱斯利·大卫·贝克在这一幕中太精彩了。我其实想给莱斯利打电话。该死。好的，莱斯利，我们要给你打电话。你必须过来。我在卡片上写了。读我写的。在贫民窟。
On the ghetto. Well, that was a fan question. Drews Fire asked about Stanley saying on the ghetto instead of in the ghetto, was this intentional? It was. It was not improvised. It was written. Paul Lieberstein wrote the line,
在贫民窟。好吧，那是一个粉丝问题。Drews Fire问关于斯坦利说“在贫民窟”而不是“在贫民窟里”，这是故意的吗？是的。这不是即兴创作的。它是写好的。保罗·利伯斯坦写了那句台词，
On the Ghetto, and there was a debate in the writer's room about which was funnier, for Stanley to say, In the ghetto or on the ghetto, on the ghetto one, Leslie David Baker delivered it perfectly. I just love how he is working Michael so hard in this scene. I loved watching Pam work Michael and then Stanley and be like, oh my gosh, they're all doing it. They're all giving him relationship advice
“在贫民窟”，编剧室里有一场关于哪个更好笑的辩论，是让斯坦利说“在贫民窟里”还是“在贫民窟”，莱斯利·大卫·贝克完美地演绎了它。我只是喜欢他在这一幕中如何努力地应付迈克尔。我喜欢看帕姆应付迈克尔，然后是斯坦利，就像，哦，天哪，他们都在这样做。他们都在给他恋爱建议
to get a good performance review. Yes, well, that's what you have to do. I also love the scene in the kitchen with Jim and Pam where it's a really quick scene where Pam's just walking to the bathroom and they just quickly download each other on the day. Oh, by the way, Dwight thinks it's Friday instead of Thursday. And then Pam says her little tidbit to Jim and they move on. That totally reminded me of me and my husband. Sometimes that's all you get. You just between packing lunches and
以获得良好的绩效评估。是的，好吧，这就是你必须做的。我也喜欢吉姆和帕姆在厨房的那一幕，那是一个非常快的场景，帕姆只是走去洗手间，他们就快速地交流了一天的情况。哦，顺便说一下，德怀特认为今天是星期五而不是星期四。然后帕姆对吉姆说了她的小花絮，然后他们就继续忙了。这完全让我想起了我和我丈夫。有时这就是你得到的全部。你只是在打包午餐和
doing laundry and pick up and drop off and all the things that keep the house running, you got to just, you'll get like two sentences out before someone needs something from you. And sometimes it's like a big reveal because like you walked by and you're like, they definitely hooked up. He's like, Oh yeah, Dwight thinks it's Thursday or Friday. Oh, great. Yes.
洗衣服、接送孩子以及所有维持家庭运转的事情之间，你只能在有人需要你之前说两句话。有时这就像一个大揭秘，因为就像你走过来说，他们肯定亲热了。他说，哦，是的，德怀特认为今天是星期四或星期五。哦，太好了。是的。
Big news. Big news, but you don't have a ton of time. Exactly. And I feel like Lee and I download one another sometimes with stuff like that, big stuff. Scenes like that make our show so special, I think, because they don't feel like a scene. You really feel like you're just watching someone live their life.
大新闻。大新闻，但你没有太多时间。正是如此。我觉得我和李有时会像那样交流一些事情，重大的事情。像这样的场景让我们的剧集变得如此特别，我认为，因为它们感觉不像是一场戏。你真的感觉就像在看某人过他们的生活。
And I think it's super unique to our show. You're just capturing a moment in time. And I also think it's such a great way to write the romance between Jim and Pam. I think that's intimacy, right? That's why it made me think of me and my husband, because they have to grab this moment of intimacy on the fly. Wherever they can.
而且我认为这对我们的剧集来说非常独特。你只是捕捉到了一个瞬间。而且我也认为这是编写吉姆和帕姆之间浪漫故事的一种很好的方式。我认为那是亲密关系，对吧？这就是为什么它让我想起我和我丈夫，因为他们必须在匆忙中抓住这种亲密时刻。无论在哪里。
Yeah. And so it really makes them feel like a couple, because you can do that with someone you're really close with. Yep. You can download big info in two seconds. Yo con. I don't know why I said it like that. Yo con. I have a card.
是的。所以它真的让他们感觉像一对情侣，因为你可以和你真正亲近的人那样做。是的。你可以在两秒钟内交流重大信息。Yo con。我不知道我为什么那样说。Yo con。我有一张卡片。
What is it? Nine minutes, two seconds. Kelly's hair is up. What? Kelly Kapoor. Hold on. Her hair is in a bun or an updo this whole episode. Oh, what is happening? I don't know.
是什么？九分两秒。凯利的头发盘起来了。什么？凯利·卡普尔。等等。她这一整集头发都在发髻里或盘起来。哦，发生了什么？我不知道。
Oh, yes. I have that too. Michael tells everybody about the suggestion box meeting and Kelly's hair is back up in a twist with a paisley shirt. But I did think that Mindy was acting more Mindy-ish. Yes. So her performance is evolved even though her hair is fussy.
哦，是的。我也有那个。迈克尔告诉大家关于意见箱的会议，凯利的头发又盘成了一个发髻，穿着一件佩斯利花纹的衬衫。但我确实觉得明迪演得更像明迪了。是的。所以她的表演进化了，即使她的头发很繁琐。
Her hair is fussy, but she's becoming more like Mindy. Angela, I have to go back though. Oh, what? We have to discuss your youth beauty pageant. Oh, yes. OK. And your love of being judged. Jake Peters asked, what was Angela's talent
她的头发很繁琐，但她变得越来越像明迪了。安吉拉，我得回去。哦，什么？我们必须讨论你的青少年选美比赛。哦，是的。好的。还有你喜欢被评判。杰克·彼得斯问，安吉拉的才艺是什么
when she was on the pageant circuit? Angela, what do you think her talent would be? There was a prop photo of me twirling a baton. I don't know if it ever made it in an episode. Oh, I remember that. Yeah. So I don't know if I was a baton twirler. You know what, if I got to pick what Angela's beauty pageant
当她在选美巡回赛时？安吉拉，你觉得她的才艺会是什么？有一张我转指挥棒的道具照片。我不知道它是否出现在剧集中。哦，我记得那个。是的。所以我不知道我是否是一个指挥棒转动者。你知道吗，如果我能选择安吉拉的选美比赛
talent would be, it would be that she would play the crystal glasses. That is so perfect. She would have a table of glasses and be like, wah, wah, wah, and she like maybe like some old gospel tune. I feel like either that or the bells. Oh, the bells. And she'd have gloves on.
才艺会是什么，那会是她演奏水晶杯。那太完美了。她会有一张桌子的杯子，然后就像，哇，哇，哇，她可能还会演奏一些古老的福音歌曲。我觉得要么是那个，要么是铃铛。哦，铃铛。而且她会戴着手套。
The gloves on. Gling, gling. Yes. Yes, those two things. Okay, I have something. At nine minutes, 16 seconds, there's another scene between Jim and Dwight at their desks. This is when Jim is on the phone
戴着手套。叮，叮。是的。是的，那两件事。好的，我有件事。在九分十六秒，吉姆和德怀特在他们的办公桌之间有另一场戏。这是吉姆在打电话的时候
and you can see that Michael's door is open and Steve is in the background. So he did not get out of that one. I like it. I like how like I would track like who was sitting with Oscar in his booth at the Dundee's. This is like Steve's door is open, Steve's door is closed. This is gonna be my thing.
你可以看到迈克尔的门是开着的，史蒂夫在背景里。所以他没有逃过那一劫。我喜欢它。我喜欢我如何追踪谁和奥斯卡坐在邓迪奖的摊位里。这就像史蒂夫的门是开着的，史蒂夫的门是关着的。这将是我的事情。
I'm just gonna be like. You're in charge of the door lady. Okay, great. I'll be door. I'm on door. Horror door. You're in charge of the door, lady. I'm... Okay, great. Okay. I'll be door. I'm on door. Hoardor.
我只是会说。你负责门，女士。好的，太棒了。我会是门。我负责门。霍多门。你负责门，女士。我……好的，太棒了。好的。我会是门。我负责门。霍多门。
Oh, you don't watch Game of Thrones. I don't. What is it? What door? Hoardor. Hoardor? Hoar? No.
哦，你不看《权力的游戏》。我不看。那是什么？什么门？霍多门。霍多门？霍？不。
Like a... Is it Ho-dor? Oh, sorry. I said it wrong. Ho-dor? It's Ho-dor. Ho-dor. Ho-dor. It's sort of the same. What happens in the, I mean, all that's coming to mind for me is prostitution.
就像一个……是霍多吗？哦，抱歉。我说错了。霍多？是霍多。霍多。霍多。这差不多是一样的。在……中发生了什么，我的脑海里只浮现出卖淫。
No! What is this door? Don't listen to my Southern accent. Hodor. It's Hodor. Even still ho? Hodor? Jenna, it's not about- What happens with the door? Just tell me.
不！这是什么门？别听我的南方口音。霍多。是霍多。即使如此，霍？霍多？珍娜，这不是关于——门发生了什么？告诉我。
Well, it's not about prostitutes, okay? Well, what is it? It's a person. Hodor is a person. Oh, it's not a door? No, but a door is involved later. I don't want to ruin it for you. It's my hope that someday you'll watch Game of Thrones.
好吧，这不是关于妓女，好吗？好吧，那是什么？是一个人。霍多是一个人。哦，它不是一扇门？不，但门后来涉及其中。我不想为你剧透。我希望有一天你会看《权力的游戏》。
I'm never gonna watch it, Angela. I'm sorry to tell you. Come on, Hodor. It's not my genre. What? Fantasy is not my genre. So you don't like Lord of the Rings? I've never seen it.
我永远不会看它，安吉拉。很抱歉告诉你。得了吧，霍多。这不是我的类型。什么？奇幻不是我的类型。所以你不喜欢《指环王》？我从来没看过。
I'm out, I'm out. She's leaving. She took off her headphones. No, you know this about me. I mean, I sort of knew it. I'm out, I'm out. She's leaving. She took off her headphones. No, you know this about me. I mean, I sort of knew it, but come on, Lord of the Rings. It's just, you know what it is? I'm not a fan of having to learn all new rules about different new planets or mythical creatures
我出局了，我出局了。她要走了。她摘下了耳机。不，你知道我这一点。我的意思是，我有点知道。我出局了，我出局了。她要走了。她摘下了耳机。不，你知道我这一点。我的意思是，我有点知道，但得了吧，《指环王》。这只是，你知道它是什么吗？我不喜欢不得不学习关于不同新星球或神话生物的所有新规则
and their powers. Hold up. What? I can't even, I almost can't say this out loud. What? What? Do you not like Star Wars? No!
以及它们的力量。等等。什么？我甚至，我几乎不能大声说出来。什么？什么？你不喜欢《星球大战》？不！
No! I'm afraid to speak right now. No, Jenna, are you kidding? You don't like Star Wars? I have not ever What? seen
不！我不敢说话。不，珍娜，你在开玩笑吗？你不喜欢《星球大战》？我从来没有看过
No. the Star Wars movies. No! Except I think as a child, I saw The Empire Strikes Back. Oh my god. I have an appreciation for Star Wars as a cultural phenomenon. Oh my god, you sound like you're a politician. Oh my god.
不。《星球大战》电影。不！除了我想小时候，我看了《帝国反击战》。哦，天哪。我对《星球大战》作为一种文化现象有欣赏。哦，天哪，你听起来像个政客。哦，天哪。
When I was a child, I went to Star Wars and I fell asleep during it. And then as an adult, I thought, what is wrong with me? I need to see Star Wars. And then you were like, but then I have to learn rules about a new planet. No, I fell asleep again. Oh my God. And then I thought that's a sign.
当我还是个孩子的时候，我看了《星球大战》，我在看的时候睡着了。然后成年后，我想，我怎么了？我需要看《星球大战》。然后你就像，但我得学习关于一个新星球的规则。不，我又睡着了。哦，天哪。然后我想那是一个信号。
I mean, in multiple generations of myself or like in different decades. Here's the thing though, I was obsessed with Princess Leia. Like as a kid, I wore the buns and I did the lightsaber fighting. But you didn't know why. No, I don't know any of the things. I don't know where Chewbacca is from.
我的意思是，在我自己的多代人中，或者在不同的几十年里。但事情是这样的，我迷上了莱娅公主。就像小时候，我梳着发髻，玩光剑格斗。但你不知道为什么。不，我不知道任何事情。我不知道楚巴卡来自哪里。
Kashyyyk. But then likewise, I love your baby Yoda. You have a knitted baby Yoda. I do. In your she shed office. And I love it. I want one, but so I guess I'm attracted to parts of Star Wars, but not the actual story
卡西克。但同样地，我喜欢你的尤达宝宝。你有一个针织的尤达宝宝。我有。在你的棚屋办公室里。而且我喜欢它。我想要一个，但我想我被《星球大战》的部分所吸引，而不是实际的故事
or any of the rules. Wow. I'm afraid that I've said this. I'm afraid. No, don't be afraid. I'm afraid to have admitted this. This feels like a little bit like I'm telling a secret. It is, no, it's, you know what?
或任何规则。哇。我恐怕我已经说了这个。我恐怕。不，别害怕。我不敢承认这一点。这感觉有点像我在说一个秘密。它是，不，它是，你知道吗？
But listen, we went to Disneyland and we rode that Millennium Falcon ride. I loved the whole Disneyland Star Wars world. Like I didn't wanna leave. It was amazing. It was so well done. And then like the ride was blew my mind. Like I've seen so much of the imagery from the movie
但听着，我们去了迪士尼乐园，我们坐了那个千年隼号。我喜欢整个迪士尼乐园的《星球大战》世界。就像我不想离开。它太棒了。它做得太好了。然后那个游乐设施让我大吃一惊。就像我看了很多电影里的意象
that I was giddy. I think Jenna that in 2020, I think you need to revisit the Star Wars. I think you have to maybe, okay. Angela. The Mandalorian, it's so good. What is that? It's on Disney Plus.
以至于我头晕目眩。我觉得珍娜，在2020年，我觉得你需要重温《星球大战》。我觉得你必须也许，好的。安吉拉。《曼达洛人》，它太棒了。那是什么？它在迪士尼Plus上。
It's so good. It's got baby Yoda in it. I, please don't make me watch all these fantasy shows. What if I bought, like. This would be like, if I said to you, Angela, in 2020, I'm gonna make you watch all my favorite horror movies. Oh, I do hate horror movies. See?
它太棒了。里面有尤达宝宝。我，请不要让我看所有这些奇幻剧。如果我买了，就像。这就像，如果我对你说，安吉拉，在2020年，我要让你看我所有最喜欢的恐怖电影。哦，我确实讨厌恐怖电影。看到了吗？
I hate them. I don't like being scared. I love horror movies, and I love, in particular, survivalist horror movies. Oh, I hate those. OK, fine. OK, fine. You can keep your survivalist movies,
我讨厌它们。我不喜欢被吓到。我喜欢恐怖电影，特别是生存恐怖电影。哦，我讨厌那些。好的，好吧。好的，好吧。你可以保留你的生存电影，
and I'll keep Star Wars. Although I do feel like there might be a night. Listen to me. Listen to me. Will you come to my house with me this year and watch my annual viewing of The Edge? And in exchange, I'll watch something of your fantasy stuff. Yes, but if I have to watch a man fight a bear, like he it's the bear's eating him and he's fighting
我保留《星球大战》。虽然我确实觉得可能有一个晚上。听我说。听我说。你今年会和我一起去我家看我一年一度的《边缘》吗？作为交换，我会看一些你的奇幻东西。是的，但如果我必须看一个人和一只熊搏斗，就像它，熊在吃他，他在搏斗
him off, I'm gonna need a glass of wine. You can have a glass of wine. It's gonna stress me the hell out. Well, Angela, what one man has done another can do. Oh my god, there it is. Okay, fine, Oh my God, there it is. Okay, fine. I have spoken. Yes, yes, Mandalorian, yes! I don't know what that reference is. I know, I know. Let's get back to the episode,
他，我需要一杯酒。你可以喝一杯酒。这会让我压力很大。好吧，安吉拉，一个人能做到的，另一个人也能做到。哦，天哪，它就在那里。好的，好吧，哦，天哪，它就在那里。好的，好吧。我说完了。是的，是的，曼达洛人，是的！我不知道那个参考是什么。我知道，我知道。让我们回到这一集，
if anyone is still willing to listen to me after that confession, the scene with Jan and Michael greeting one another where he accidentally touches her boob. Yes. I know, do you remember on the day, we rehearsed that scene, because it was a little tricky. There was a big camera movement of Michael watching the door, waiting for Jan and then
如果有人在那个坦白之后还愿意听我说的话，简和迈克尔互相问候的那一幕，他意外地摸了她的胸部。是的。我知道，你还记得那天吗，我们排练了那一幕，因为它有点棘手。迈克尔看着门，等待简，然后有一个大的摄像机移动
he comes out of his office. So it was a little complicated. We had to really rehearse that with the cameras. And during the rehearsal, Steve accidentally touched her boob. Yes. And we all laughed so hard. Melora was cracking up. Melora said, you have
他从办公室出来。所以这有点复杂。我们必须真正用摄像机排练那个。在排练期间，史蒂夫意外地摸了她的胸部。是的。我们都笑得太厉害了。梅洛拉笑得前仰后合。梅洛拉说，你必须
to do that in a take. And Steve was like, no, no, no. And she's like, no, it was so funny and awkward. You have to. And so then that became a bit in the scene. Then they had to try to do it where it still looked like an accident, which is a really hard thing to do actually. Yeah, because he was to recreate that. I think Steve was just trying to pat her shoulder and missed. Yes, she sort of moved a little bit and he accidentally patted her boot. She turned into him as he went to pat her shoulder. So funny. So funny. That was a complete accident, that bit. That just happened on the fly. I also want to say that then when Jan goes into Michael's office, I love that the cameras are outside of the
在拍摄中那样做。史蒂夫说，不，不，不。她说，不，这太有趣和尴尬了。你必须这样做。所以后来这就成了场景中的一个桥段。然后他们不得不尝试这样做，同时看起来仍然像是一个意外，这实际上是一件很难做到的事情。是的，因为他必须重现那个。我想史蒂夫只是想拍拍她的肩膀，但没拍到。是的，她稍微动了一下，他意外地拍到了她的胸部。当他去拍她的肩膀时，她转向了他。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。那完全是一个意外，那个桥段。那只是在匆忙中发生的。我也想说，当简走进迈克尔的办公室时，我喜欢摄像机在
office during this scene between Michael and Jan. So Paul Feig talked about his decision to keep the cameras outside the office for these scenes. He thought that Michael might want Jan alone so that he could ask her about the relationship. And Jan would not want the cameras there anyway. No, probably not. And so they had to get it as a spy shot. But then later, after the suggestion box meeting,
办公室外面，在迈克尔和简的这一幕中。所以保罗·费格谈到了他决定在这些场景中让摄像机保持在办公室外。他认为迈克尔可能想让简单独相处，这样他就可以问她关于关系的事情。而且简无论如何都不想让摄像机在那里。不，可能不想。所以他们不得不把它作为间谍镜头拍摄。但后来，在意见箱会议之后，
you'll notice that the camera is inside the room with them. And Paul said that his logic was that in Michael's mind, if he let the cameras in the office with him, maybe Jan couldn't yell at him as much for what happened in the conference room. Oh, yes. So Michael would be able to use the camera as a buffer. As protection. I just love the thoughtfulness that
你会注意到摄像机和他们在一起在房间里。保罗说他的逻辑是，在迈克尔的心里，如果他让摄像机和他一起在办公室里，也许简就不能因为会议室里发生的事情对他大喊大叫了。哦，是的。所以迈克尔将能够利用摄像机作为缓冲。作为保护。我只是喜欢那种
goes into the planning of where the camera is or where the camera isn't. I mean, that's just Paul is so smart. He's so smart. Well, I loved the line that Jan had when she said, please don't smell me, Michael. Oh, yes. He's like, what are you wearing?
投入到规划摄像机在哪里或不在哪里的深思熟虑。我的意思是，保罗太聪明了。他太聪明了。好吧，我喜欢简说的那句台词，她说，请不要闻我，迈克尔。哦，是的。他就像，你穿的是什么？
It smells sexy. She's like, oh, god, don't smell me. Please don't smell me, Michael. That yes. He's like, what are you wearing? It smells sexy. She's like, oh God, don't smell me. Please don't smell me, Michael. That reminds me so much of Pam's line, please don't throw garbage at me. Me too. It reminded me of the same thing.
闻起来很性感。她说，哦，天哪，别闻我。求你了，别闻我，迈克尔。那个是的。他说，你用的什么香水？闻起来很性感。她说，哦，天哪，别闻我。求你了，别闻我，迈克尔。这让我想起了帕姆的那句台词，请不要往我身上扔垃圾。我也是。我也想到了同样的事情。
Hey guys, just a little fun background thing to catch. There is a British flag on Michael's desk. You see it throughout the episode whenever you go into his office. I like to think it's a little nod to our BBC roots. It must be. Right? I think so.
嘿，伙计们，有一个有趣的小背景细节可以留意一下。迈克尔的桌子上有一面英国国旗。每当你进入他的办公室时，你都能在整集中看到它。我喜欢认为这是对我们BBC根源的一点致敬。一定是这样。对吧？我想是这样。
They would do stuff like that. I know. So I don't know if you guys noticed it, but I noticed it right away. In the conference room, 12 minutes, 26 seconds, we are opening up the suggestion box. We had a fan question from Real Brandon B16. What was the hardest scene for you to film
他们会做这样的事情。我知道。所以我不知道你们有没有注意到，但我立刻就注意到了。在会议室，12分26秒，我们正在打开建议箱。我们收到了来自Real Brandon B16的粉丝提问。对你来说，这一集最难拍摄的场景是什么？
for this episode? This one. We laughed so much. So hard. I laughed so hard at every one of Steve's reactions. Everything was so, and also like Reina's Dwight, like repeating all the ridiculous things. So good.
这一集？这一场。我们笑得太厉害了。太厉害了。史蒂夫的每一个反应都让我笑得不行。一切都太……还有雷纳的德怀特，重复那些荒谬的事情。太棒了。
Also, I think in this scene, there's some Toby sass. Oh, I wrote major Toby sass. Okay, so wait, first of all, can we just briefly talk about how many cards are in the suggestion box? Yes, please. There are six. Okay. Number one, what should we do to prepare for Y2K?
另外，我觉得在这一幕里，托比表现得有点刻薄。哦，我写了“托比的重大刻薄时刻”。好吧，等等，首先，我们能简单谈谈建议箱里有多少张卡片吗？是的，请说。有六张。好的。第一，我们应该做些什么来为千年虫做好准备？
Amazing. Number two, we need better outreach for employees fighting depression. Okay, that was Tom. Number three, you need to do something about your BO. This is when we have major Toby Sass. Cause he's like, Michael, aren't these about you? And he's like, I mean, I can't believe, first of all, I can't believe Michael didn't kick him out
太棒了。第二，我们需要为抗击抑郁症的员工提供更好的外展服务。好吧，那是汤姆写的。第三，你得管管你的体味。这就是托比表现得非常刻薄的时候。因为他说，迈克尔，这些不是关于你的吗？他说，我的意思是，我简直不敢相信，首先，我不敢相信迈克尔没有把他踢出
of the conference room. Yeah. Right? And I think he only didn't kick him out cause Jan was there. Yes, good call. Also, can we all just take a minute to witness the fact that Creed like schooled Michael and the difference between inferring and implying?
会议室。是的。对吧？我想他没把他踢出去只是因为简在场。是的，说得好。另外，我们能花点时间见证一下克里德像教训迈克尔一样，解释了“推断”和“暗示”的区别吗？
Yes. Like what, Creed? I love when Creed suddenly lays down real wisdom. Yeah, and we're like, what? Yeah, he mostly says gibberish and then you're like, oh, okay, take note. Inferring and implying are two different things. What? Number four, you need to do something about your coffee breath, brush and then you're like, oh, okay, take note. Inferring and implying are two different things.
是的。比如，什么，克里德？我喜欢克里德突然说出真正智慧的时候。是的，我们当时想，什么？是的，他平时大多说些胡言乱语，然后你会想，哦，好吧，记下来。推断和暗示是两回事。什么？第四，你得管管你的咖啡口气，刷牙，然后你会想，哦，好吧，记下来。推断和暗示是两回事。
What? Number four, you need to do something about your coffee breath, which was clearly my character's card. Yes. Yes. Number five, a piece of gum. Number six, don't sleep with your boss. Yes.
什么？第四，你得管管你的咖啡口气，这显然是我角色的卡片。是的。是的。第五，一片口香糖。第六，不要和你的老板上床。是的。
Yeah. I personally never came back from the gum. When he opens up the piece of gum and Steve's reaction to the gum, I don't think I ever got it together after that because it was so amazing. Also watch Mindy at 15 minutes, 10 seconds. She puts her hand over her mouth, but her eyes get really wide.
是的。我个人从来没从口香糖那一段缓过来。当他打开那片口香糖，看到史蒂夫对口香糖的反应时，我觉得我之后就没法正常演戏了，因为它太精彩了。还要留意15分10秒的敏迪。她用手捂住嘴，但眼睛睁得很大。
Like she's totally, it's a total giveaway she's laughing. That's what Mindy does when she laughs. She covers her mouth with her hand. Yes. That's her tell. All right. So now we're going to move out to the stairwell and the scene where Dwight is pumping himself up for his performance review. To the song Wild Side by Montley Crue.
就像她完全……这完全暴露了她在笑。这就是敏迪笑的时候会做的事。她用手捂住嘴。是的。那是她的标志。好了。现在我们要转到楼梯间，那是德怀特为绩效评估做准备的场景。伴随着莫特利克鲁乐队的《Wild Side》这首歌。
Yes. So that is the stairwell to the writer's offices. The bottom of the stairs is the hallway where our editors would sit. That's where the editing bays were. And upstairs was the writers. And Rain has said in interviews that this was one of his favorite scenes to film. And I happened to be over in the writers' room that day
是的。那是通往编剧办公室的楼梯间。楼梯底部是我们的剪辑师坐的走廊。那是剪辑室所在的地方。楼上是编剧们。雷恩在采访中说过，这是他最喜欢拍摄的场景之一。那天我正好在编剧室，
that they were filming it, and I sat at the top of the stairs and I watched him film the scene. Yes. And it was so great. And a lot of the stuff that he is saying there was improvised. Yes, also people were like, did he improvise playing the air guitar?
他们正在拍摄，我坐在楼梯顶上看着他拍这一幕。是的。太棒了。而且他在那里说的很多话都是即兴发挥的。是的，还有人问，他弹空气吉他是即兴的吗？
That's all rain. That's all rain. And there was something funny about that. So usually when you have music in a scene, they don't actually play the music on set. In fact, they'll be like a big dance scene or a club scene, like let's say you're shooting a wedding. They'll play a few seconds of the music
那全是雷恩的即兴。那全是雷恩的。关于这一点还有件有趣的事。通常当场景里有音乐时，他们实际上不会在片场播放音乐。事实上，比如一场大型舞蹈戏或俱乐部戏，假设你在拍婚礼。他们会播放几秒钟的音乐，
so that you can get the beat. And then they turn it off, and you have to dance. With no music. With no music and say your dialogue. And then they add the music later in editing. And that's so they can get your dialogue clean and so that they can cut between different takes. You don't want this song in the background. Well, for this scene, they actually played the music
这样你就能找到节奏。然后他们关掉音乐，你必须跳舞。在没有音乐的情况下。在没有音乐的情况下说你的台词。然后他们会在后期剪辑中加入音乐。这样他们就能得到清晰的对话，并且可以在不同的镜头之间剪辑。你不想让这首歌在背景里一直响。好吧，对于这一幕，他们实际上在
on the boombox. It made for a bit of a challenge in the editing room, but Greg felt like it provided so much to Rain's performance for him to have that music blaring. And also it's documentary. So you wouldn't have this clean track of the music playing later. Although we did in Cafe Disco, we all have the dance to nothing. I remember that. Yeah. In the little Michael Scott Paper Company thing.
收音机里播放了音乐。这在剪辑室里造成了一点挑战，但格雷格觉得让音乐大声播放对雷恩的表演很有帮助。而且这是纪录片风格。所以你以后不会有这种清晰的音乐音轨。虽然我们在《咖啡迪斯科》里确实那样做过，我们都得在没有音乐的情况下跳舞。我记得那个。是的。在那个小小的迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司的事情里。
All right. So now we move into Michael's office and Dwight is gonna give his pitch for why he deserves a raise. Okay, this scene happens at around 17 minutes, 14 seconds. I just have to tell you guys, I did a lot of scenes with Rainn Wilson and here's something you have to know about him. The man loves a prop.
好了。现在我们进入迈克尔的办公室，德怀特要为他为什么应该加薪进行游说。好的，这一幕发生在17分14秒左右。我必须告诉你们，我和雷恩·威尔逊拍过很多戏，关于他，有一件事你必须知道。这家伙热爱道具。
He loves a prop, guys. It does. Oh my gosh. So it was no surprise to me when he held up that binder. I have a feeling him and Phil Shea talked a lot about that binder and what would go in it, but Rain loves a prop. Well, you can see at 18 minutes, 12 seconds,
他热爱道具，伙计们。确实。天哪。所以当他举起那个活页夹时，我一点也不惊讶。我有预感他和菲尔·谢伊肯定讨论过那个活页夹以及里面应该放什么，但雷恩就是热爱道具。好吧，你可以在18分12秒看到，
speaking of props, there is a sign and it never gets referred to in the scene because it got deleted. Dwight has made a sign of himself where he breaks down his name. I wrote it all down. I did too. Okay, say it, Anne. Let's take turns.
说到道具，有一个标志，但在场景中从未被提及，因为它被删减了。德怀特做了一个关于他自己的标志，他拆解了自己的名字。我把它全记下来了。我也记了。好吧，说出来，安。我们轮流来。
You do the first one. Well, let's go back and forth. Okay. Dwight's acronym for his name. Determined. Worker. Intense. Good worker.
你先来第一个。好吧，我们轮流。好的。德怀特名字的首字母缩写。坚定的（Determined）。勤奋的（Worker）。强烈的（Intense）。好员工（Good worker）。
Hard worker. Worker. Intense. Good worker. Hard worker. Terrific. You actually, I have to advise people to go back and watch the deleted scenes from this because there is a whole scene where he explains this. First he explains it to Jim at their desks, and then he makes suggestions for what Jim's acronym could be. He does? Yes, and it's really good.
努力工作的（Hard worker）。员工（Worker）。强烈的（Intense）。好员工（Good worker）。努力工作的（Hard worker）。极好的（Terrific）。你真的……我必须建议大家回去看看这一集的删减片段，因为有一个完整的场景他解释了这个。首先他向吉姆解释，在他们的办公桌前，然后他为吉姆的名字缩写提出了建议。他做了？是的，而且非常精彩。
And then they also show the scene from Michael's office, so it's good stuff. It is interesting to me that the two characters that were the most excited about their performance review were Dwight and Angela. I mean, Dwight put so much effort into his and then all Michael said was he's adequate. And then my character is like, I love to be judged. I think I hold up even to the most severe scrutiny. I'm so excited for this. And then he just slams the door in my face and says, you're satisfactory. Oh, I know. It's so sad that two people who really wanted a performance review don't get it. So around 18 minutes, Jan is fed up.
然后他们还展示了迈克尔办公室里的场景，所以内容很棒。对我来说有趣的是，对绩效评估最兴奋的两个角色是德怀特和安吉拉。我的意思是，德怀特为他的评估付出了那么多努力，结果迈克尔只说他“合格”。然后我的角色说，我喜欢被评判。我想即使是最严厉的审查我也能经受住。我太期待这个了。然后他直接在我面前摔上门，说，你“令人满意”。哦，我知道。两个真心想要绩效评估的人却没得到，这太可悲了。所以大约18分钟时，简受够了。
She's like, you know what? I need a minute. I'm going to step out. I'm going to collect my thoughts. And she goes into the hallway and we see the sign for the building. And here's what's in the building that we see. WB Jones Heating and Air. That's in office 110.
她说，你知道吗？我需要一分钟。我要出去一下。我要整理一下思绪。她走到走廊，我们看到了大楼的标志。这是我们在大楼里看到的：WB琼斯供暖与空调。那是在110办公室。
Available 1400. It's available space. And then the number is 120. What? Then we have Dunder Mifflin Inc. Suite 200. And then we have Vance Refrigeration Suite 210. So here's something that's interesting. We haven't done that episode where
1400室可用。那是可用空间。然后号码是120。什么？然后我们有邓德·米夫林公司，200室。然后我们有万斯制冷，210室。所以这里有一件有趣的事。我们还没有拍到那一集，
we meet all the people in the business park yet, but they had to make that prop. Yeah. So I want to ask, that would actually be set deck. meet all the people in the business park yet, but they had to make that prop. So I want to ask, that would actually be set deck. I want to ask Michael Gallenberg, did he just randomly make up that JB whatever? WB. The WB and did he make up Vance Refrigeration? WB Jones.
我们还没见到商业园区里的所有人，但他们必须制作那个道具。是的。所以我想问，那实际上应该是布景装饰。我想问迈克尔·加伦伯格，他是随便编造了那个JB什么的吗？WB。那个WB，还有他是编造了万斯制冷吗？WB琼斯。
I mean, Vance Refrigeration is put there so far before we ever deal with it. I wonder like what that was, who came up with that. Yeah, we need to talk to Michael about all of those little things because they will come to figure so prominently in upcoming episodes. Oh my gosh. Bob Vance, for example.
我的意思是，万斯制冷在我们要处理它之前很久就放在那里了。我很好奇那是什么，是谁想出来的。是的，我们需要和迈克尔谈谈所有这些小细节，因为它们在接下来的剧集中会变得非常重要。天哪。比如鲍勃·万斯。
Bob Vance, Vance Refrigeration. Then we have the scene with Jim and Pam in the break room. Yes, they're talking about Michael and Jan. And Pam says, how do you come back from that? And Jim so clearly takes it to heart because he's thinking, how would they come back if him and Pam hooked up and it didn't work out? How would they come back?
鲍勃·万斯，万斯制冷。然后是吉姆和帕姆在休息室的场景。是的，他们在谈论迈克尔和简。帕姆说，你怎么能从那件事中走出来？吉姆显然把它放在心上了，因为他在想，如果他和帕姆在一起了，结果却没成，他们该怎么面对彼此？他们该怎么走出来？
How would he come back from that? It's so clear to me that that's what he's thinking. And he's like, yeah, you know, I don't know how you do come back from that, especially if you work together. And then Pam goes, no, I mean, how do you come back from hooking up with Michael? Right.
他该怎么从那件事中走出来？我很清楚他在想这个。他说，是啊，你知道，我不知道你怎么能从那件事中走出来，尤其是如果你们还一起工作的话。然后帕姆说，不，我是说，你怎么能从和迈克尔上床这件事中走出来？对。
And he's like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, Michael. But you see the whole time, I feel like Jim sort of went deep and I feel like Pam kind of stayed surface. Yeah, I don't think Pam's thinking any of that stuff at all. She's really thinking, Jan hooked up with Michael. Yeah, Michael.
他说，哦，是的，是的，是的，迈克尔。但你全程都能看出来，我觉得吉姆想得比较深，而我觉得帕姆还停留在表面。是的，我不觉得帕姆在想那些事。她真的只是在想，简和迈克尔上床了。是的，迈克尔。
Yeah, she's not thinking office romances. But it's just a little moment for me that kind of broke my heart. And it's kind of like what Larry is talking about, that at the heart it's a romantic comedy. And Jim is thinking about Pam. And so when he realizes Pam hasn't even clocked that, that he's thinking about them in a way
是的，她没在想办公室恋情。但这对我来说只是一个小瞬间，让我有点心碎。这有点像拉里所说的，核心是一部浪漫喜剧。吉姆在想帕姆。所以当他意识到帕姆甚至没意识到这一点时，他在以一种她在那一刻甚至没想到的方式思考他们。
that she's not even thinking about in that moment. Jan then says she is heading back to New York and there's this big scene where Michael chases her to the elevator. Oh, Jenna, before we get into that scene, I just have one little comment about something in the background. What is it?
简随后说她要回纽约了，有一个大场景是迈克尔追她到电梯。哦，珍娜，在我们进入那个场景之前，我只想对背景里的东西发表一个小评论。是什么？
At 19 minutes, eight seconds, you guys, as Jan is leaving the building and Michael's chasing after her, you really get a great look at the Dunder Mifflin sign. Oh yeah. Here's the thing, you probably think that sign is like made of something hard and sturdy, right? Doesn't it look like plastic or something?
在19分8秒，伙计们，当简离开大楼，迈克尔追着她时，你真的能很好地看到邓德·米夫林的标志。哦，是的。事情是这样的，你可能以为那个标志是用什么坚硬结实的东西做的，对吧？看起来不像塑料之类的吗？
Yeah. Composite, it's foam board. Yeah. Sometimes- It's like almost like a craft project. It's almost like a poster you would make for your kid's third grade project. I remember we would have scenes where we'd have to line up and come in and out of the office and we'd be stuck back there in that little corner off camera and you could just
是的。复合材料，其实是泡沫板。是的。有时……它几乎就像一个手工项目。它几乎就像你为孩子三年级作业做的海报。我记得我们拍戏时不得不排队进出办公室，我们会被困在镜头外的那个小角落里，你可以直接
push on it. It was just like foam board. Well, I used to remember being worried for it because it did feel very precarious. Like if you, your elbow might go right through it. I remember one time Oscar was leaning on it and I was like Oscar, the D is getting like all like bent. Stop it. Like, yeah. Anyway, I'm just saying that sign guys, you know, it's Hollywood smoke and mirrors. It's just foam board. You could have made it for your third grade project. I love that tidbit. I think that's a good tidbit. It's a good tidbit.
推它。它就像泡沫板一样。好吧，我记得我曾经为它担心，因为它感觉非常不稳定。就像如果你……你的手肘可能会直接穿过去。我记得有一次奥斯卡靠在上面，我说，奥斯卡，那个D字母都要弯了。停下。就像，是的。总之，我只是说那个标志，伙计们，你知道，那是好莱坞的烟雾弹。它只是泡沫板。你完全可以为你的三年级作业做一个。我喜欢那个花絮。我觉得那是个很好的花絮。是个好花絮。
I would sometimes walk past it and just push on a letter. Angela. What? That's so, like, devious. I could tell. It felt funny. Was that like your character just getting out a little tension?
我有时会走过它，然后推一下字母。安吉拉。什么？那太……太阴险了。我看得出来。感觉很有趣。那是你的角色在释放一点压力吗？
I don't know. But sometimes I'd walk past it and go squeaky. So Jan gives this big speech at the elevator, which is amazing. It's amazing. Melora is amazing. Amazing. And it cuts back and forth between them at the elevator and all of us in the office.
我不知道。但有时我会走过它，然后发出吱吱声。所以简在电梯旁发表了那段精彩的演讲，太棒了。太棒了。梅洛拉太棒了。太棒了。镜头在电梯旁的他们和办公室里的我们之间来回切换。
We had a fan question from Molly Smiley Face. When Jan is leaving and her and Michael are arguing, could you guys actually hear it or did you just act like you could? We could hear them. We could hear them. They had a camera on us and we could hear them and it was as much fun to listen to as you would imagine in real life.
我们收到了来自Molly Smiley Face的粉丝提问。当简离开，她和迈克尔争吵时，你们真的能听到吗？还是你们只是假装能听到？我们能听到。我们能听到。他们把摄像机对着我们，我们能听到，而且听起来和你在现实生活中想象的一样有趣。
It would be fun to listen to that. Oh yeah, we had a camera on us the whole time. They did their scene. And so I think what people don't realize too is the space from reception to that elevator wasn't very far. No. It really wasn't. So we were in fairly close proximity. It just doesn't look like it the way we would always film. And also the walls aren't really real thick walls.
听那个肯定很有趣。哦，是的，他们全程都有摄像机对着我们。他们演他们的戏。所以我认为人们没意识到的是，从接待处到那个电梯的距离并不远。不。真的不远。所以我们离得很近。只是我们拍摄的方式让它看起来不像。而且墙壁也不是真正的厚墙。
Yeah. You can hear. Yeah, they're just drywall. And also the elevator is obviously not a real elevator. It is a box with a door with like a guy with a pulley. With a cable. Yeah, he would like pull the doors open and shut. And he would have to try to time it to look real. But something I love in this scene is that the timing of Michael saying, so what you're
是的。你能听到。是的，它们只是干墙。而且电梯显然不是真正的电梯。它是一个带门的盒子，有一个带滑轮的人。带着缆绳。是的，他会拉开和关上门。他必须努力把握时间，让它看起来真实。但我喜欢这一幕的一点是，迈克尔说“所以你的意思是，这和我的长相无关？”的时间点，
saying is it had nothing to do with my looks? Like that that's his takeaway from that speech is that she doesn't find him unattractive. And she just goes, and then the doors close. That's perfect. I mean, amazing. And then this is, you know, a little background tidbit that I love at 19 minutes, 14 seconds while Melora, as Jan is having this speech we see the door to Vance refrigeration there it is there it is
他从那段演讲中得出的结论竟然是她并不觉得他没有吸引力。然后她就走了，门关上了。那太完美了。我的意思是，太棒了。然后这是，你知道，我喜欢的一个小背景花絮，在19分14秒，当梅洛拉饰演的简在发表这段演讲时，我们看到了万斯制冷的门，它就在那里，就在那里，
that's where they are they're right on the other side so you can see that Phyllis and her fella weren't very far apart they weren't I wonder where did they meet in the elevator maybe the elevator or did they know each other before hmm we all have a lot of questions mm-. We learn about that romance in the Christmas episode, which is coming up. All right. So here we go. We talked about cold opens.
他们就在那里，就在另一边，所以你可以看到菲利斯和她的男朋友离得并不远。他们确实不远。我很好奇，他们是在电梯里认识的吗？也许是电梯，还是他们之前就认识？嗯，我们都有很多问题。嗯……我们在圣诞那一集里了解到了那段恋情，那一集快到了。好了。所以我们开始吧。我们谈到了冷开场。
This episode has a tag. A tag. The little tidbit at the end. It's the next day. Where is Dwight? If you re-watch this, this is one long tracking shot, which is just a great shot. It's kind of amazing how we timed it out.
这一集有一个片尾彩蛋。一个彩蛋。结尾的小花絮。那是第二天。德怀特在哪里？如果你重看这一集，这是一个长镜头跟踪拍摄，这是一个很棒的镜头。我们把握的时间点真是太神奇了。
You see everybody working and then we go to the window, you see Dwight down at the window getting out of his car. It's really terrific. The prank worked. He doesn't get to work until like noon or something. Yeah, he comes barreling out of his car, all frantic. And of course you see the really cute Jim and Pam that they do a little like actors bow to each other.
你看到每个人都在工作，然后我们转向窗户，你看到德怀特在窗边下车。这真的很棒。恶作剧成功了。他直到中午左右才来上班。是的，他从车里冲出来，非常慌乱。当然，你看到了非常可爱的吉姆和帕姆，他们互相鞠了一躬。
Like well done. Yes, yes. And that is performance review. That's performance review. We would love to thank Larry Wilmore for coming on today and you guys for tuning in. And we will be back next week. With email surveillance.
就像，干得好。是的，是的。这就是《绩效评估》。这就是《绩效评估》。我们要感谢拉里·威尔莫尔今天来到这里，也感谢你们的收听。我们下周会回来。带来《电子邮件监控》。
And guess who's gonna be in the booth with us, Ken Jong. Yes, and Angela, this is gonna be a big episode for you. Oh yeah, it is. Dwight and Angela, Dwayangela is born officially. Bump and Birkenstocks. Woo, all right, we'll see you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf.
猜猜谁会和我们一起在录音室，肯·郑。是的，安吉拉，这对你来说将是重要的一集。哦，是的，确实。德怀特和安吉拉，德怀特安吉拉正式诞生了。碰撞和勃肯鞋。呜，好了，到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。
Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reiss-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。